welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
[Applause]
you do it for the men but it's like
sexual tension it's not your
relationship attention so you can kind
of do a cheat code you can go get a BBL
get a nice body and you do get more
attention from men than if you're flat
right but here's the thing though no no
but but listen though if it goes so
deeper though because I know what you're
talking about and she has a great body
yeah so you got to think about how far
down deep that she is within watching
the Instagram models within watching The
Cosmopolitan magazines
doesn't look good to a man but you think
that men have higher standards for women
not that the men have the higher
standards they have to live up to just
to clarify I think men have highest end
is for women for women so like the women
have higher beauty standards to me yes
and that's what's making women feel like
they need to comply with these standards
who's pickier men or women men women are
more complacent than men
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all of them and do you think men
are very like if they've they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women I think men are pickier than women
100 definitely but they will not marry
they will not settle down with somebody
with a fake or lips the eyebrows and if
they do it ain't gonna last I so I I
done an only fan I thought it wasn't
like vagina boobs it was lingerie yeah
builds right whatever I'd done it and
when I finished it I felt very degraded
I felt very like why did I actually do
that now I know there's girls out there
who do that they don't feel that way
that is perfectly fine you do you you
feel the way you feel but me personally
like like in the future how like when I
have kids and all in the future and if
my kids found out about that they'll
probably get bullied in school there are
people like oh your mom doing this your
mom doing that and your man as well he's
not going to if you don't respect
yourself and you're selling your body
online I can't speak for everyone I can
just speak for myself if you're selling
your body online like that there's not
there's not a high respect for yourself
yeah
what up guys welcome to the just
apparently things YouTube channel and
welcome to the pregame
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos like the video on your
way in and as you guys already know if
you have watched two or more of my
videos and you don't subscribe we have
beef okay beef people a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first is that we have four
membership tiers the first tier lets you
be a part of our live chat tonight
bossing how many likes to open up the
chat
one thousand a thousand likes and we'll
open up the chat to everyone tonight
second tier you get to get to be a part
of our Discord and our behind the scenes
Vlogs third tier you connect with me on
social media and the fourth tier you get
a one-on-one call with me once a month
guys if you want to know how to get a
million subscribers in a year I'll tell
you sign up for that call and I can also
give you tips and behind the scenes info
on how to run a network and a live show
also guys
um follow my Instagram I got it deleted
for a day but I'm back they they let me
back on so it's just pearly things one
um also guys go subscribe to wife school
and
make sure you sign up you follow our
talent channels Auntie Jenny and King
Richie's those should be in the
description
um also guys
[Music]
um
oh just subscribe to just pearly
animations and our two clips channels
just pearly clips and pearl daily make
sure you go subscribe to both okay guys
welcome to the show um to start everyone
say your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact starting here and
then going around okay
Emma I'm 41. I'm officially separated
um I live between here and Ibiza okay
hi my name is Aline I'm 23 years old and
I'm just currently unavailable
hi my name is Renee I'm 19. I'm in a
relationship and fun fact I'm a law
student
hi my name is Gabriella I am in a
relationship and fun fact is that I'm an
actor
hi my name is Pia I'm 25 and my fun fact
is I'm like a full-time tick tocker I
guess
hi I'm Nathan I'm 29
um I've got misses and fun fact is just
yesterday I just got certified to be a
development tool coach from him
okay so today's topic
birth control ruins women
so I'm going to read a study published
in the proceed in the proceedings of
Royal Society B researchers investigated
whether the menstrual cycle of women
affects the way she perceives the
attractiveness of male faces they found
that women's preferences for masculine
facial features varied across their
menstrual cycles with women showing a
stronger preference preference for
masculine features during the ovulatory
phase of their cycle
this study has been replicated in
several subsequent studies which have
been confirmed which have confirmed the
initial findings the research sheds
light on the complex interplay between
hormones and mate preference and
provides important insights into how
women's attraction to masculine traits
can change through their menstrual
cycles
okay so first question have you ever
been on birth control and then for you
it would be have you ever dated someone
on birth control start here and go
around yes yes
no no yeah
I have the employment
right now your preference in men change
when you are on birth control
I think preference to a lot of things
change when you're on birth control so
yes yeah um tell me more how
um
I think sex drive goes down I think
messing with your hormones is just a
negative thing okay and are you still on
it or did you end up going off no I
ended up coming off okay I've got two
daughters now okay and did you feel
better when you came off of it 100
literally about six months after I've
stopped taking the pill I felt like I
could see that the sky was blue really
how long were you on it
um probably about 10 years and I did it
for 10 years yeah so from
being
um probably 18 or 19 until 30.
um and I also had the implant as well I
just think any of they're all basically
hormonal so they're putting extra
hormones into your body so it definitely
has an effect okay and what was like the
number one side effect that you had like
negative
um yeah like just
a sadness I just think it really really
so you made you depressed yeah I think
so on a level definitely it wasn't I
didn't know that when I was on it but I
just remember that day when I remember
it sort of clearing from my system and
looking at the sky and going Oh What a
Beautiful Day oh wow
um okay what about you
um I think it's an interesting question
I don't really know I think I've got the
implant this is my second implants I'd
say now I've been on the implant four or
five years now and I would say for on my
menstrual cycle my emotions and stuff
either heightened or decrease but I feel
like maybe the implant has over
heightened or decreased it a lot so you
feel like you're more emotional on birth
control it's maybe slightly but I feel
like I've kind of always been that way
anyway on my menstrual cycle so I don't
feel like it's affected me emotionally
as such but I think physically I take my
menstrual cycle is kind of just been a
bit more inconsistent or had like a
consistent pattern that I don't like but
I wouldn't say emotionally it's like
affected me as a woman okay so before if
so if you had a friend that knew you
before you're on birth control and after
she would say you're the same yeah
people don't even really they don't know
know that I'm even on birth control I'd
say yes okay what about you you said
you've never been on it I just feel like
you know when people like you ask people
about birth control and stuff like they
never have anything good to say like
obviously there's the benefit that it
stops you from getting pregnant and
stuff like that cool but when you ask
people people there seems to be more
like ones than there are pro so it kind
of just puts me off like obviously I'm
young so I don't have as many years to
try things and stuff like I have had but
you know it just doesn't appeal to me
like at all have any of your friends
taken it yeah some of my friends have
been on it but it's the same thing that
they just every day they're complaining
like how they feel depressed and stuff
like no all the side effects that just
come with it like I just wouldn't want
to put myself in that position and have
you noticed I'm outside of them just
like saying that if you noticed them
acting different being on it like I feel
like with my friends that were more
outgoing before like now they've been on
it they're more like they want to stay
at home and stuff like that like their
social status like it changes and I just
feel like for me personally like I'm
young I don't want to feel like I don't
want to go out and I like live my life
just because I'm on the pill like I want
to go out and I want to have fun and
stuff like you can be safe but you know
there's other ways to do it
um what about you
um yeah I've been on birth control
um I think for me like um I think it
makes me more emotional at times
um and sometimes I'm like I'm this
really outgoing person I feel like
sometimes it just makes me feel like oh
um second guessing myself at times um I
think that's like the biggest effect
I've seen it have on me but otherwise
fine so it's it's been minimal side
effects it sounds like do you know
anyone that's had major side effects
from birth control I mean I've had some
friends who've had like major weight
gain and it's taken them a couple of
years to get it off
um and other side effects oh I think
mainly for them it's the mood swings you
know they're just not themselves or just
probably a little bit more angry at
times
um yeah mainly
and are you still on it yeah okay yeah
um what about you
um I'm on birth control I've never
really had any issue with it I was on
the pill from when I was like 18 to 21
came off for a few years and then when I
was 25 now I'm on an implant and never
had a problem also on the topic of
weight gain I've heard that like there's
actually no studies to say that there is
any link whatsoever between birth
control and weight gain but sometimes
they think that women see that
correlation because they tend to start
taking birth control like when they go
to university which tends to me because
I've had that part before yeah I've
always wondered if because people start
drinking a lot at University it's
because like there is a correlation
between starting University and gaining
weight
um but not actually between birth
control and gaining weight there's um
there's this thing where because you
have more hormones it enhances your
female assets
um and it's not the fact that it makes
you gain weight because you're on birth
control but it creates more of um
uh um or hunger for food and so that's
where the weight gate comes in is that
you're feeling like you want to eat more
probably like sweet stuff or
um your favorite kind of meals and
that's where the weight gain comes in
rather than because you're on it for a
long time that you're just putting on
weight yeah I get that from like an
empirical point of view from like your
own experience but I don't think there's
actually any studies to back it up from
what I've read myself about and the
birth control because that was one of
the things when I was like 18 I went on
it I was like oh my God it's gonna make
me fat because then I was skinny but
like
um apparently there are actually no
studies to back that up or there when I
was 18 anyway well for the one I've done
it's in the aspect of it increases your
your um hunger so it changes I've heard
that that it makes you more hungry yeah
I don't know if it's true like from that
because I mean like you speak to the
nurse and you're like okay I'm gaining
weight and then when I did research is
because it enhances like your food
habits or it's not like you're just
putting on but you're eating the things
that for example like when you're PMSing
you'd probably want a chocolate or women
tend to eat like their favorite foods at
that time of the month and I think
that's like a bigger increase basically
have you ever dated someone that's on
birth control
yeah um um my misses so we're coming up
to maybe like two years now uh for the
first year she was on birth control not
anymore and did you notice a difference
in her
Behavior no but then to be fair to be
fair she that's the reason why she came
off right because she did say that you
know she just wasn't herself when she
was on it and it does affect her mood
swings big time so I just kind of had to
take that on just say fair enough
um so how did you guys make the decision
to go on birth control was it for acne
hormones or was it you started dating
someone how did you start I think it was
like 16 17 18 when you start having sex
with a partner it was it was nothing to
do with periods or anything like that
it's just purely birth control okay yeah
that was the same for me it was just
strictly how old were you about 18. when
I first went on the implant yeah so yeah
it was interesting but I had the same
like theories of putting them away and
always being on your period or having to
I think with the implant which you might
know is that sometimes people take a
pill on top of the implant because it
really fluctuates your cycle so I was a
bit skeptical but I could never remember
to take the pill every morning so I was
like let me just do that
um what about you know you were when did
did you ever consider it
um no like not really like I just
literally I've never ever felt like I
want to do it or like it's a good yeah
like it's a good decision so I just
decided not to okay what about you um I
made the decision so I've been on and
off of it because of relationships so I
think I first went on it by choice at I
think 19 or 20. that's when I made the
decision that yeah because I was seeing
someone I just thought
um no she's not ready to be a mom so I'm
like no no even though he is protection
I'm just like I I don't I don't even
think my partner at the time knew I was
on it because it was just for me in
terms of like as a backup really
yeah for me is when I was in my first
long-term relationship when I was 18
um and then again like I was in that for
a few years came off and then just used
condoms for a period of time and then
again when I was back into a serious
relationship
um I went on the implant
have any of you ever told a guy you were
on birth control when you weren't
isn't that like
kind of creepy
yeah do you know what I mean
no yeah everyone no I think that is you
have to be transparent about that have
you ever heard of anyone doing that yeah
yeah yeah firsthand yeah yeah yeah tell
me what did she do
um yeah
she she told him that she was on and she
wasn't and
she got what she wanted she got pregnant
off of it yeah
do you do you think that in that
situation since she lied that he
shouldn't have any rights to the or that
he should be able to get rid of his
rights to the kid
I mean no because she lied so he was he
was performing off of something that you
know off of the security that she was on
it and she wasn't so that kind of no but
I mean so when he has the kid or when
she had I'm assuming she had the kids
right so did um
do you think that in that case that he
should be able to sign off all rights
because he didn't want the kid to begin
with I mean when you say it like that
because it it's it's in a way where it
wasn't his choice because had he known
he wouldn't have made that choice
um so when you say like that absolutely
I mean rightfully the kids there at the
end of the day so I mean whether he
wants it or not unfortunately that's his
seed that's his future
um but yeah it is in his hands to make
that decision
um but then it comes into do you want to
be a father what type of Father do you
want to be to that kid that you weren't
ready for but now you are a father now
so yeah what do you who who do you know
that lied
oh I I know someone that got into a bad
situation because they um well they
didn't like they were in birth control
but they lied that they were bulimic
um so they didn't disclose their bulimia
so they were making himself sick while
taking birth control
um which obviously makes it ill
effective
um and she she did get pregnant and did
you keep it yeah yeah
they they worked things out and like
they're a happy couple now but
um it was a big I lived with them it was
a big point of contention at the time do
you do you guys think that should be
punishable as a crime
you take accountability that's so so I
feel quite passionate yeah it's so
unfair on the man if if you lie about it
like yeah obviously if an accident
happens there's an accident right both
parties fault but yeah if you lie about
it then yeah a hundred percent it feels
like premeditated yeah exactly it's like
coercion in a way it's similar to like
essay of a woman if you like about
having an STD is that I would say that's
like a similar thing but I don't think
that means you should sign away all
right to the baby it's not it's not the
baby's fault no I mean yeah but you
don't think if the woman has the right
to get an abortion he should have the
right to sign off his rates no because
like you don't think if the woman has a
right not to be a mother he should have
a right not to be a father especially if
he was coerced into doing it no because
I was like if a woman abortion is
different sorry like so if um if a
woman's graped I have to say grape do
you think she should be able to get an
abortion yeah but I think is different
to when the baby is at the point of a
baby in your arms I think that that is
your life responsibility and when you
have sex in general you take the risk
whether someone's lied to you about the
risk or not isn't it that's a terrible
thing to happen but you still take the
risk of that one percent of um oh this
woman could get pregnant even if you
think she is but what if the woman wants
to give up the kid for adoption should
she have that right
uh not if the father wants to keep it no
yeah if the father wants the baby the
father should be able to have full
custody in the woman should pay child
support no but I'm saying I'm saying if
she wants to give up the kid for
adoption she should be able to right
yes but not if the father wants yeah but
but so I'm saying if he didn't sign up
to be a father like why should he be
forced to because isn't it like
rewarding bad behavior no I think that
when every single time you have every
time I have sex with my boyfriend there
is a small percentage chance that I
could get pregnant and we both have sex
knowing that that can happen when you do
it with a stranger you know that that's
a yeah but the women are that we're the
only ones that can have all the
information up front so yeah but that
that's my point my point is like there's
no male birth control so what women we
we can when we have sex like we have all
the information we know if we're
ovulating we know if we're going to take
a plan B we know if we're on birth
control we're the men it's like they
have the they have the option condom or
no condom but even with like Plan B
that's not that effective because if you
are Plan B only works to delay ovulation
so if you're ovulating at the time that
you have sex yeah but it does nothing
yeah but there's 41 forms of birth
control for you and you only can get
pregnant like three days a month there's
still people do it all the time that's
why 16 year olds are pregnant you know
it's never deliberate
[Music]
in this case it was deliberate yeah so
it's just interesting because I I feel
like if he's not able to sign off his
rights when she does something wrong
like why wouldn't she just keep doing it
why wouldn't women just keep doing it I
just I don't think that that's a real
problem and I think women are actually
doing that oh my gosh you you haven't
seen the NBA the NBA issued statements
telling the men to wear condoms because
all these models were lying to the men
about being on birth because it's a real
issue I mean do you think Drake wanted
to get pregnant porn star pregnant
that's like a very specific issue based
on very very wealthy men like when you
have a lot of wealth and you have a lot
of like Fame you are obviously at more
risk of people taking you to court of
people abusing you in every single way
so like that's a very specific thing to
NBA stars they're like you're Average
Joe but it happens to a lot of men that
aren't NBA stars and I think there's a
lot of men that are in I'd say
comfortable positions that women would
want to be in that situation with them
and see an opportunity I think you know
there's a lot of women out there that
sometimes even just get to a state where
they become selfish because they might
receive news that they might not be able
to ovulate as much in the next two years
or whatever the situation may be I think
on both behalfs it is kind of selfish in
a sense where I think it's wrong when a
woman does that anyway because that's
unfair on the child forget about even
the man's rights the rights as a child
to be able to be accessible and my
parents to both be accessible I think is
so important so me taking away the
opportunity of my child having their
father in their life before they're even
here is selfish so before we even get to
a point of the man's rights what about
that that that child's rights 100
you know
you said you're you said you're
passionate about it why
yeah I just I just don't you don't have
someone that's happened to
um had stories yeah I think it's
happened to a couple of the boys
actually
um but yeah it's just something that is
just so unfair and I just feel that
um yeah men just literally have no right
at all they have no say and if it is
something that's deliberate for me I
just don't think a baby deserves to be
brought up in that type of World
um especially if the father's not ready
and it's come from a lie so I think the
baby so I think the Dad should have a
decision on you know what happens to
unfortunately the baby especially if
you're both young but the dad has had a
decision to put a condom on in the first
place right he made that and she could
poke holes in
I mean that's gonna be she's gonna be
pretty obvious if she's got a lot if
she's gonna lie about being on birth
control then you know that does happen
people do put pins through
I know it's a rarity there's still
condoms you know
in that case though even if like a man
is coerced into
um having that child I still think he's
taken the risks anyway even if he
thought it was a much Slimmer chance
than it was
um and that woman should be treated as
if she's treated but then don't you
think in the case of abortion like that
she took that risk
like I'm just it's just interesting
because I this sounds like equality when
it benefits it's not real equality
what do you mean by like when abortion's
involved so a woman has the right not to
be a mother so if I if I have an
accidental pregnancy I can terminate it
up to six months in the UK but men don't
have the right not to be fathers so it's
like why why do we call the man a
deadbeat dad but we don't call the woman
a deadbeat mom and she gets an abortion
and so I'm saying if we really want
equality like why wouldn't we make it
equal where the men can sign off but I
think that's like how again we'd want an
Ideal World to be do you know what I
mean in a sense where I would but she's
saying no fair enough to society like
that's the way Society is and
unfortunately that's how can I put it
like I'm fortunate on the men's behalf
in the world because that's something
that they're out of control of there's a
lot of things I'd say like in a
relationship or in other situations us
women are out of control of and I think
like what
oh sometimes I think women Chase we want
a man to be with us and it's not until a
man decides for commit that we get that
relationship I'd say we're more prepared
for them than they are so right but we
can always pick who we go after so if we
go after the top 20 of men you have to
compete for then then it's the ball's in
their court but for the average guy
there's Bennett Tesco down the street
that would date you tomorrow but it's so
true but I guess so so it's really in
our control because we pick who who we
go after and if you want to go after
someone more competitive it's going to
be harder true but then I feel like them
men sometimes take advantage the fact of
the fact that they are part of that 20
and then sell women dreams instead of
allowing a woman to actually make that
decision for themselves like for example
you might meet a guy like you said NBA
player football or whatever he's not the
guy down the road at Tesco's however he
could have children that no one knows
about I mean look at Khloe Kardashian
poor her you know ready to have her next
child she didn't even know I don't know
an ounce of sympathy for Khloe
Kardashian you're telling me I'll stop
it she dated Lamar and she right right
that was her first husband's name Lamar
yeah right right yeah so she dated Lamar
and she said hmm NBA player this ended
with him in a whorehouse let me try
another NBA player and another NBA
player and then they do the same thing
and then they're like maybe she's gonna
play victim later but then men then come
off with but why are you judging me
because you went with an NBA playoff
just because
what does it mean that I'm not Kim so I
guess you just can't win I guess it's
just because the luck of the draw to be
honest no I don't think it's the luck of
the draw I think if you get if you get
with an NBA player you're probably gonna
be cheated on miracles happen but you
know you know what I just learned um
there's a guy he like Works um I
interviewed him he makes like very
high-end suits right yeah and so he some
of his clients are professional athletes
and those those men
um he said he was in like box seats or
whatever whatever it was the ones next
to the it was ice hockey I think I don't
know what they're called but but he um
he said the two of the most beautiful
women he's seen in his life are sitting
by the by the box seats basically
motioning to the guys that they'll have
a threesome with them these women buy
hotels next to the do the court and like
chase after these men yeah but I think
again a lot of them are predatory true
and I agree with that and I also believe
that I think
being logistic whilst women sometimes we
fantasize over things and want things
without actually knowing what comes with
it so me I would actually not go for an
NBA player or want a footballer for
their money or whatever it is because I
know what comes with that I want to be
the only woman in that man's life I want
to be appreciated so I'm willing to in a
sense like not be with that person or
care to be of that person because the
morals that I have and the values that I
have so so what worth more why do we
have sympathy for Chloe it's like come
on she she dated Lamar I get it but
there's women that are not Khloe
Kardashian or Lamar or NBA players that
go through similar scenarios that still
feel the same way she's still human she
still was tricked into a situation
regardless whether he's you know his
past history what he's done before she
couldn't see that she couldn't foresee
that we can't see tomorrow you know you
know I'll give you one guy that can
trick you but it's like girl you slept
with the whole team what did you think
was gonna happen it's the same thing
over and over again I can't support you
on that one
it's like okay you start eating out what
16 yeah 18. how long are you going to do
the same thing over and over again and
expect different results I think with
Chloe is different because she Tristan
cheated on her once already after her
first baby and she still won't have
another baby with him yeah so it's like
the only reason why I think that she was
not clear in that situation is that she
trusted that he changed just because he
said that he changed you know what I'm
saying yeah so that is
I think
um he was willing to wife I mean like
what'd you expect is the grass going to
be greener on the other side now you're
home split yeah like at least if she
stayed like the next guy's probably
gonna cheat too she might as well they
date athletes they date celebrities but
you think she's gonna marry the Plumber
she might as well stain but the father
of her kid sorry go ahead I was just
gonna say I think with a lot of these
arguments that the whole unfair this
unfair that I think the problem is that
women do look at that top 10 percent of
guy as the majority of men there's a
whole what's that start isn't it like
women find like literally 80 of men on a
Truck Yeah women like you guys are
forgetting that average man like Chloe
sorry yeah Khloe Kardashian she could
have gone for the guy that works at
Tesco's or 7-Eleven in America what you
did what that she went to date the top
of the top all right NBA players so or
she could have even gone for like the
businessman yeah you know what I mean
she didn't but she's going for the
entertainers like what did you I mean
like it's is because she will constantly
be in the news like you have to like you
when people so when women are in these
sort of situations right there's a lot
that comes with it and they accept it so
she knows she's going to be cheated on
okay it's gonna bring her in the news
every day she's gonna be the Hot Topic
um you know there's people there's women
who get cheated on and they'll say oh my
God he's cheated on me again but like
they're accustomed to that and that's
something that they'll accept they
probably because of media wise they'll
be like oh no that's a really bad thing
but in the back of their mind they know
and sometimes like they say how you get
a man is how he's gonna leave you for
the next woman like it's just a fact so
sometimes when they're like whoa me they
know the situation before they come into
it and they just accept it but face wise
they have to act like it's affecting
them and but they have this all planned
out I mean you know and I think and I
feel like you know women I'd say they
definitely
they definitely get attracted to the
wrong things and I feel like sometimes
that's why it goes wrong because how you
start is how you mean to go on and I
think you know with I'd say with myself
if someone's trying to be flashy in the
beginning trying to show off you know
even drive a nice car speeding I'm like
bro my life like please t-shirt Tony
marks power or just let me take the bus
or something jump in my own car but like
I have to see you underneath all of that
what are you showing me other than that
because anyone can buy me red bottoms
anyone can buy me a Louis bag anyone can
take me to one of the best restaurants
anyone you've got multiple Louis bags I
mean no but I'm just saying like anyone
listen yeah
anyone what I'm saying is anyone can go
at their work make money and do that for
someone how much is a Louis bag I mean
it depends on what one you're buying
is that like 5 000
depends on the Range you know
you guys have people buying you thousand
dollars
women will offer to do that because they
feel like they need to do that to get
you but then they moan about you know
women only wanting them for that that's
all you're putting out and again women
then feed into that and then get upset
like you said that they're cheating or
actually I can't get through to you half
time in a day or whatever it is but then
things was not what you was focused on
from the beginning so how can you expect
that now and I feel like that's where it
goes wrong because they're chasing the
wrong things from a man I'm curious how
important is money to you guys in a
relationship a man's money I don't think
money's necessary it's like drive an
ambitionist sexy so you can be a
gardener but if you want to be the best
Gardener and that's like the driving
ambition so he's making 25 000 pounds a
year as a gardener you don't care no not
anymore
um when you were younger you did quite
possibly okay I've got like a deeply
personal story to talk about with regard
to the birth control thing that I wasn't
going to talk about but I will
um
my ex-husband uh this happened to him
what happened to that we've been talking
about he met a person after we split up
she got herself pregnant he now has a
baby that he didn't want and yeah so
there's also the Ripple effects so I've
got two daughters they now have a
brother
that they don't know about so it's not
just about those two people in that baby
there are Ripple effects so I think
my view is that men should have a choice
I think the baby should be in the world
so they get they can they're not not the
way we can be in the world but because
then you can't do so you can the baby if
she wants to have the baby that's her
choice meet the baby then decide if you
want to be in a baby's life how has that
affected your family
um currently not
um sorry that's probably not the right
sound to make
um my girls don't know so that's a young
oh they don't have any idea no
um but obviously it's uh
yeah it's got a ripple effect onto
everyone
um did that happen like while you guys
were together literally straight after
wow yeah
would you ever think about getting back
with him no no but not for that reason
no there was reasons why I ended in the
first place but yeah I mean that's
definitely a uh like a seal the deal
kind of situation
hmm But yeah so I do think men should
get the choice because I think if he had
the choice then
and what did she do she lied she poked a
hole in the condom or she lied I think I
don't know the ins and outs really bad
terminology but um
no I think she's told him that she
couldn't get pregnant but I mean he was
a 40 year old guy he could have used a
condom he was not 16 he doesn't know
what's going to happen right I think she
said it wasn't her time in the month to
get pregnant like the three-day thing
you're saying from The Narrative that
I've been told but um
he's a Portugal guy he should if you
definitely don't know you don't want to
have a baby and you definitely know you
can use protection come out a few
questions yeah of course you can babe
you know when you say it happened just
after like key split do you do you have
any feeling that it could have been
happening just before that happened
quite possibly okay yeah uh the time
frames are all um I'm told what I'm told
yeah
when you said I'm driving ambition
um so what about you guys
um is how important is money to you guys
I think it's important but I don't know
if I'm just saying that because like I'm
younger than everyone like me personally
like I feel like at this age that I want
to go out I want to have fun and stuff
like that but like if I'm gonna be in a
relationship then I feel like I want to
be with somebody who can live that life
with me like go on holidays and stuff
like that obviously when I'm older you
know you want to be focusing on like
Investments and stuff you want to have a
house you want to have a car and stuff
you want to be able to support yourself
financially but I just feel like when
you're my age like I want to go on
holiday I want to go party I want to you
know buy all the expensive stuff go
shopping because I don't have any real
responsibilities right now but yeah for
me like if I'm going to be dating at
this age I want someone who can spend on
me do you do you expect him to cover all
the bills when you go out not all the
bills I mean give me specifics how often
do you need to be taken out in a week
like I don't mind like going out like
once a week so once a week yeah if we go
out once a week how expensive is the
dinner
[Laughter]
if the dinner's like we're going out to
like an expensive place and we're going
to like Mayfair or something like he can
cover the bill but if it's like his
birthday or something like I'll pay no
but I'm talking day to day see once a
week you expect the Mayfair no once a
week like we could do something basic I
don't mind will be good like I don't
mind just being around you but if we're
gonna go out and like get something even
if it's basic like a McDonald's or
whatever like you have to page and if
you lived with him would you expect him
to pay a hundred percent of the bills no
50 50. no like maybe like yeah maybe
like 80 20 or like 70 30 years cost of
living in London is expensive I know but
yeah that's just how I practiced it do
you know how much he would need to make
to do that
not really like I just feel like it just
depends like if you're making like a lot
of money then I feel like it goes up you
know I mean like if you're making a lot
of money say I'm not making as much as
you just yet then you want to live
together then maybe it's gonna be like
more maybe like what do you what do you
mean like if we're living together and
you're making more money than me at this
age like say I'm still in uni I'm not
like actually working yet but you want
to live with me then I feel like the
bills have to be more on your side like
you have to support me and talk but if
you were making more money then you'd
contribute so after you graduated
University you'd be like 50 50 so yeah
I'd actually I'd actually like split 50
50 if we're making around around the
same amount we're both working and
getting good pay then 50 50 is fair what
about height is that important to you
yeah because I'm like I'm not like super
tall but I'm a tall girl like I'm five
eight so that I don't want to be I get
it I'm six yeah yeah I get it I don't
want to be with no one who's like short
of me like I feel like
[Laughter]
so how old are you again I'm 19 19. okay
so if he's let's say 25 is that is that
no cage or is that too old what for me
yeah for you that is too old
okay let's let's go down 22.
20 21 21. he works at Tesco you cool
with that
no no oh he's only 21. he's just
starting off you know what if he works
at Tesco but he has ideas of going
somewhere else then that's fair but if
you were you're working at Tesco's and
Tesco's the only place you have your
mindset like this is the only way I'm
gonna get money cool I'm just gonna stay
here then it's something from me okay so
is there a dollar amount that he has to
be at
um I'm just trying to paint so he's a
six foot guy maybe I know something
maybe I
like as long as
you can be financially stable you know I
mean like if we're cool we can afford to
like do the grocery shopping and stuff
like that like all the luxury stuff like
it comes as a bonus you get what I'm
saying but like you know so at this age
it sounds like looks are more important
to you than money yeah because the
height thing seemed more important you
see more fussed about the height than
the money yeah like I feel like for me
personally like if I'm in a relationship
with someone right now like if we go out
I can pay for them do you know I mean
like I can treat them how I want them to
treat me but I feel like as well if
you're going to be in a relationship
with someone you have to be attracted to
them like that's the bottom line I feel
like obviously everyone's on this oh
love is blind blah blah blah like for me
like I'm not going to be with someone
who I'm not attracted to that's just
that's just how it is it's crazy though
it's true you ever look at Super Rich
guys
Jeff Bezos I look at him and I'm not
actually attracted to him but he's Rich
so girl I'm telling you some
money gives girls glasses
you'd be surprised
um okay um so you seem like you cared
also more about looks or money
um just because you said you didn't care
about money earlier I'm assuming you
care more about looks but I could be I
think it's like looks and attract being
attracted to someone can be quite
different you can be attracted to
someone by someone's aura and how they
move and stuff like that I think you can
looks fade
um and it's just the way someone holds
themselves their presence and stuff like
that you could like look at them and not
necessarily think that they're
attractive and in five minutes you're
like I'm in so like pretty eyes is
enough okay so looks is more important
than money or money is more important
than love no I think like presence and
Vibe is more important than either of
them so Charisma yeah
charismatic yes exactly okay um what
about you
um
what how how tall does he have to be
well I'm five five so do you know what
it is yeah I've actually dated a couple
short guys so I can't even talk too
tough I can't lie but I'd say like
obviously I'd want him to be over my
height or just a little bit taller
depends I don't really want a tall tall
guy because like if he's moving a bit
mad I need to be able to bad him up just
a little bit you know I mean can't be
feeling a bit but if you wait say it
again
no so he's moving a bit mad you need to
like humble him just a little bit you
know what I mean okay so I'm gonna need
a frame so let's say he's five he's five
seven he's five seven he's feeling
himself what are you doing
what do you mean feeling himself like
he's being rude I guess I don't know
whatever you're just give me a situation
I'm gonna cost him or something Johnny
but I'm saying if I'm a six foot guy
right or five foot seven like that's
quite two actually yeah five foot seven
and then I'm gonna go for six foot and
then he's like he's I don't know
cheating or just something mad or like
he's just messed he's sexy sexting women
okay so has this happened no okay that
one's been raping off okay so five seven
guys sexting other girls yeah after
school I watched Tyler Perry yeah one of
them Madea movies and it stuck with me
since and I took it I said God bless me
with this because basically he was
cheating and like she had kids of him
and stuff she actually done she put on
lingerie he came up from his business
trip went my business trip right he was
with another woman but she thought he
didn't know
and then she like basically said like
she's got the shower running for him and
everything she took everything out of
the bathroom she put baby oil on the
floor so he would slip and slide and
then she just like whipped him with his
belt I said yeah I'm taking that one for
the boat okay so if he's five seven oh
you're gonna need to do that you're
gonna so if you catch him cheating
you're gonna essentially abuse him
obviously I need to be able to kind of
just put a little bit of fear like bro
this is just major disrespect you think
okay you think a guy who most men can
beat you up easily yeah agreed he's
gonna be afraid of you no that's why I
need the baby oil
okay okay so but if he's six foot what's
the difference
I don't know he's just met like yeah he
could just literally just pick me up my
neck like just whoop okay so all right
so so you you need to date the guy
that's five seven so you can potentially
if he cheats on you
hurt him in the shower by making him
slip on me no no no that's not the
question but what I'm trying to say is
no I'm just trying to give out that
basically I just prefer not so tall men
because I find them sometimes
intimidating that's all it is and I feel
like some men the tall men are
intimidating yeah and I feel like
sometimes not saying a short man can't
also be intimidating or he can't have
like mannerisms that make you feel
intimidated but I'm just saying for off
of looks like you say like what you're
attracted to and stuff like that that
just kind of put me off at someone's
like really tall for me you want a man
that you can dominate
no not a man I can dominate but I'd want
a man that I feel like isn't gonna give
me a reason to want to dominate
okay yeah so if he is do you think that
a guy gets a little bit more freedom
when he's taller like you'd let him get
away with more
um because he's better looking taller
now you would treat them exactly the
same no I treat them exactly so only the
baby oil for the five seven I'm just
spitting out no disclaimers guys next
minute now please give me no no sorry
I'm just gonna say no I was gonna have a
little talk pack my stuff and I'm gone
okay so it sounds like would money be
more important than looks to you
um I'd say money in a sense of ambition
because after ambition the money will
follow yeah well ambition is money
though ambition is just money later yeah
so when girls say that it's like so I'm
not gonna go over the currency of money
I'm gonna go over the currency of
ambition is a lot more important to me
than the currency overlooked okay so if
he's how old are you 23 okay so um let's
say 45 year old guy Jason he looks good
though he looks he looks younger all
right okay right no that's what you say
about 40 year olds my mom will kill me
but and maybe maybe you're a little
older at this point let's say let's say
you're you're 30. okay okay but he's got
ambition but he's 45. and he's ambitious
hmm
I mean he's only he said 25 years to be
ambitious you know
yeah I mean no my only point is it is
money it's just money later
maybe yeah okay fairies but it's not
from the I'd say like a from a a bad
perspective I'm I'm looking at the
moment it doesn't have to be yeah I mean
I think most of you if you had daughters
would not want them to date completely
broke men right it doesn't have to be a
negative thing yeah so yeah I'd say then
money more than looks yeah money more
than looks okay
um uh what about you
um money definitely she's easy
I am quite independent so if you can't
match me or hire no because I've been
there done that you know supported my
boyfriends when you know they had little
struggles no so for me that's like a
number one thing you have to have money
you have to be stable and that's that's
just literally it would you date a guy
you weren't that attracted to but he was
more financially stable
um I don't think so no
because it's I don't want his money I
just want him to have his money so for
me but if you have your own money what
does it matter if he has money because I
don't want to be dipping in mine to give
him like that's where it comes he has to
dip in his to give you when he takes you
out on dates that's his choice you know
like I'm not saying oh to be with me you
have to have money and pay all the bills
I'm not saying that I'm just saying that
you need to have yours and I need to
have mine and then we'll be good so it's
not anything where I'm supporting you as
a man you know I have to look at the
examples that my father has and my
father he's he's secure in his bag you
know like I'm curious
um and you don't have to answer this if
you don't want to
um do you make more than 70 000 no okay
so the actin's not working just yet but
soon give me give me the rest of 2023.
okay
um but I'm the sort of person I'm
financially stable like I have savings
you know I have like money to put to buy
a house so for me I can go months
without working and I'll be fine so if
I'm that sort of woman then
my partner needs to have some sort of
stability or else
I'm all the things that I've worked hard
for I'm now pouring into him and when
you're in a relationship you pour into
your partner but it has to be to a
certain extent you know I you need to
match me or else then there's issues
financially if the woman's you know for
me supporting the man constantly and I'm
not getting any kind of
like what what do I respect out of you
as a man if if you're not even
financially stable and that sort of you
know what is financially stable to you
roughly how much
um I wouldn't say
you need to at least from I don't look
at it as yearly figures or at least
probably income of two and a half three
grand a month at least at least because
rent is probably a grand you know your
um utility bills your you know all that
stuff probably takes up another 300
pounds so so you said three grand at
least two okay give me give me give me
what you want give me that you're saying
in a real world yeah or in London living
lifestyle no I'm asking what do you want
so
yeah it needs to oh my gosh can we pull
up can we pull up the delusion
calculator
can we do you know what that is the
Google delusion calculator just says
what percent of men make this okay let's
see it's okay is that my minimum was
that my maximum
yeah that's also take home so you've got
to take the taxes yeah I was going to
say is that after or before that's after
time
no you might not be delusional I don't
actually know I'm just saying I wanted
to know I wanted to know what percent of
men make that amount of money 2.5 a
month I think that's like okay let's go
female delusion calculator okay there's
this female yeah so I mean there's a
male one too but the men it's like not
so bad usually that's
that's happening
it must have been a man who created this
yeah this is female delusion I mean men
create most things in general
uh go back
uh
no go back I think it's an ad
yeah
um
yeah there you go okay so put your put
in your age are you able to put it so
they can see your reactions like wall
okay
like make it small
I think blessing oh there we go can you
put in the middle a little bigger all
right thank you
okay so what age
my age-old partners like yeah what age
could he be he needs well I don't date
too high up so I'm 30 so he needs to be
30 to 30 till 33.
uh 30 to 33 Okay do you care about race
I won't go 35 but yeah we put him 30 to
35 okay but 29 to 34.
okay
uh can you make the Box slightly bigger
I just I'm having a hard time reading it
or can you zoom in on the page
yeah there we go yes yes thank you you
can still see that okay make it a little
bigger no it's fine I have a good
eyesight I just need to book an
appointment
yeah so uh race do you care about race
um sorry yeah I do care about racism
yeah black okay now how no Prejudice to
the other races but I'm I'm comfortable
with black first all right everyone has
a type no we're I'm not shading anyone
um minimum height oh
I didn't used to care about height but
my boyfriend he's actually six four and
I think that's like really cute
um as long as they're not shorter than
me no five seven to six five seven to
six six four six and then minimum income
what I want one or can he be can he be
overweight
um what's overweight
obese like how much it's like 30
something percent body fat do you mean
like he can't fit through the door obese
or like I'm it's fine I don't health is
something that can change okay so that's
okay minimum income
minimum three grand
so let me put that I'm going to do the
conversion for you because I don't
actually and this is yeah you want tax
on top of that he's going to be earning
like 70 grand a year at least okay
okay so you could be after tax I don't
mind okay so how how much so three grand
that's your final answer yes okay three
thousand
pounds
this isn't uh
3700 US dollars so that's times twelve
that's forty four thousand that's not
bad um US dollars
okay wait now so what percent of men do
you think fit that criteria before we do
it
um at least
at least 30 percent okay wow
the age of the race is
three percent did we do America
it's similar it's similar wow
so three percent three percent yeah go
ahead your turn
go ahead your turn wow put it put in
your criteria
oh yeah your turn oh no okay it's okay
you know I eat I'd say 25 to 30. foreign
guys if you didn't hear um King forgot
to exclude married people so it's
probably 1.5
um okay race did you say I'm gonna go
for any race anyways okay
minimum height
um five seven
ex obese no include obese minimum income
no discrimination by Me by the way it's
just my preference people
um I think it's okay to discriminate and
who you should be discriminating you
should discriminate and who you date oh
there's not people say discriminate with
me but anyway
so minimum income I think she should be
picky with who you sleep with yeah come
on that's true you're straight
um minimum after tax I'd say take home
at least 2.5 okay
that is
three thousand one
130 I can't do math so I need to
calculate it times 12. okay that's 37
000. okay that's off the tax I'm gonna
go for
in the this is the yeah
okay 40 is fine
what do you think what do you think I'm
gonna go for 15 15 okay go down
[Laughter]
just get like higher so
um I want to go like 38.
no actually I want to go 40. if there's
any can you do five years or can you do
more than five years
like 38 to 48.
what about married man you're gonna go
for a married man take them off take off
the take off those married men
not worried about the race minimum
height 511. oh
I feel you minimum income it's got to be
over 100 a year
by the time you're there right so 100K
in
pounds yeah okay so that's a hundred and
roughly put 120 US Dollars that's
roughly what percent of men
I'm hoping when they get to that age
we're looking like early 20s
21 22 22 a man yeah
graphs
wow 0.49 wow my pool is small like one
percent of them one percent of people in
the UK are earning and over 100. oh my
god wow and that's all Races that's
girls you better choose now
um go ahead oh okay um let's see like 18
to that 23.
and I'm no married man
Oh Black
um
six foot
um um
oh no no these people
respectfully
um
let's do like TK per month
so that's yeah
um 2K is roughly
two like three we'll do Americans no I
need to calculate it
um
uh that's two five American so that's
times twelve that's thirty thousand
um
um what percent of men do you guys think
that is I would like ten no not two you
think low oil
oh my God
wow how much money do you think young
men
more than that what do you think like 2K
is a lot for someone yeah that's when
you go into like uni and stuff like that
you're figuring things out
but like reflect someone who's like just
going straight into work and is like
working full time
yeah they won't get that this is why men
are struggling
I used to do Recruitment and I I haven't
gone to UNI and I used to recruit people
that had just come out of uni and they
were you're going on like 23 some
companies might give you 26 like max if
you're just coming but you can obviously
make commission on that but again that's
a good six nine months if you're putting
in that hard work like hours yeah did we
do the whole couch everyone's gone on
the couch yeah
money
okay do your do your thing oh but I
didn't I don't I think money is vulgar
so don't ask about it I don't talk about
money but like I just will assume based
on like what we're doing and like where
you're taking me yeah you have money
yeah I like I have no idea how much my
boyfriend earns he just owns a business
and he handles his own finances so good
job you got him
okay so how How old uh when you were on
the market
oh that's a really hard question to be
asking because I have to eat Old I have
gone old before but like no I'm not
judging you but now I'm trying to have
babies so I've gone like younger
isn't that counter I would think that's
counterintuitive so before I was saying
a guy like who was like middle-aged then
he'd like already had his kids and stuff
oh here it is so now I'm dating a guy
like in his mid-30s because he's you
know
um so like I don't know it depends if
I'm dating for like marriage so how old
are you again I'm 25 okay so 20 would
you go no I wouldn't go younger than
myself okay so 25 is the minimum 40.
yeah okay
I'm 26 so that's roughly mine too
um okay any race oh yeah anyways
I I'm not I don't really have any height
restrictions
I think yeah
so five foot
yeah I I don't I think if I fell in love
with them it wouldn't bother me
so five foot you're good yeah okay put
her five foot I don't think that many
percentage of people are five have you
ever have you ever dated a guy shorter
than you yeah I've dated someone five
six before uh wait no I'm five foot five
I've dated somebody like my height okay
but not shorter but I don't meet many
men shorter than me because yeah I'm
just not a type woman to say like I'm
cool of men it's smaller minimum income
I don't know
[Music]
um
like I just I I just you know I've never
really talked about money I don't look
at the bill and I can't it's like my
boyfriend pays for things but like I
just don't like but then also when I was
younger like I when I was 19 like my
boyfriend paid for everything and he was
18 and like he didn't have any money
yeah he was not paid for everything he
just took me to things within his means
do you know what I mean yeah so if
money's I'm just asking a rough estimate
so you're looking to marry a guy like
30k or if I want to have his babies like
I want him to be able to support my
children I guess I could compat my
salary so that's like roughly 40 US
roughly yeah yeah
what percent I'm gonna guess like 20.
wow I'm gonna guess 20. it also depends
on your circle though because I don't
know any men that earn less than that
go down down oh 12.
does this surprise you guys
does it surprise you no
women always come up with these crazy
numbers for men oh they're going 100
Grand no they don't yeah to be able to
earn a liver you don't need to be added
as much as you as you think
um even to be able to support support a
family I know times are getting harder
because of the cost of living but um
yeah I think it's just world and this is
why red is struggling societal pressure
lack of communication is the main main
reason why men are deleting themselves
um it's such a huge problem it's a bit
of an unspoken concern because of this
hmm and that's what
so tell me why did you say 120k
just think that's like
um
what like the from being married and
stuff like that that's where our
financial position was so that's kind of
like my Baseline
you don't do you but I'm not assuming
that I'm not earning any money at this
point and he's like I'm also working and
providing like equal yeah but men don't
care about your money it's like nothing
to them
yeah but we're talking about my opinion
on it not their opinion no no but I'm
saying you just said that you would be
working too and I'm saying to the guy
like they wouldn't care okay do you not
do you not care
I'm a little bit I mean I've been quite
fortunate to date girls that have earn a
decent amount of money especially when
I've been younger it is nice but it's
not like a it's not a it's not a major
deal I mean like I could happily get a
girl that works at McDonald's if she was
a nice girl okay really what do you guys
think that men look for so if you were
to list like five things that men look
for what would you say God I've really
been out the game for a while so I think
I'm not the right person to ask
yeah but you're in it now so what do you
you gotta not really really if you want
to get this guy right you got to know
your target
your markers like it's like too soon
it's too soon I'm working on me but you
didn't learn anything about like what
your husband liked if you were married
that long
not me
um
you didn't learn anything how long were
you married 10 years two you were
married to a guy for 10 years you didn't
learn anything about men
clearly not because he left so
um
I don't know I don't know how to answer
that question okay uh what do you think
man what I think they won a woman that
gives them space to be them hmm
um I also think they want someone that
like supports them I always believe I
think I come from quite a traditional
um background in terms of like family
and like how things run I'd say
um so I think a woman that allows him to
be the head but still can be the neck
that holds him through whatever it is
that you both need to go through
um I think someone that says peace you
know someone that can bring some form of
Tranquility into his life when
everything feels like it's all over the
place or to just actually just you know
just be at peace and not bring so much
like problems or always moaning or
plucking things out of thinner to make
something happen from past trauma or
whatever it is
um I think that's what men kind of look
when again I'd say that looks or some
sometimes it could be body but I
wouldn't say it is I think it depends on
what stage they're at in their life if
they're willing to just like mess around
and just want bear things I feel like
that's what they focus on but I think
when they're ready to settle down it's
just a woman that can ground them
what do you think I feel like I wouldn't
be able to say like just five things but
like I feel like in my relationship I
know that like my boyfriend tells me
that for him it's important that I can
give him space that he can grow into the
person he needs to be but as long as he
knows that I'm gonna be there to wait
for him to get to that point then he
feels secure in that you know I mean so
I feel like men want somebody who's
going to be there with them because for
men they want to be able to turn around
and say yeah I went through ABCD but
this woman stood by me the whole time so
that's why she gets to reap the benefits
now so loyalty yeah loyalty is really
important for men like obviously
everybody wants to be with a loyal
partner like men or women but for men
it's really important like it's so so
important that they can have somebody
who grows with them because they want to
build with their women they don't want
to like just make the money and then get
a girl who's only come after the money
you know I mean they want somebody who's
been there the whole time so that they
feel like this person actually deserves
now to reap the benefits of what I've
made because they've been there the
whole time
anything else so you would add
other than loyalty
um the dog's loyal I think so what can
the girl bring I think how she carries
herself as well like if you're somebody
who's
you know you don't carry yourself well
in public you have a bit of a reputation
for yourself it's going to make them and
look at you a bit sideways like do I
really want this person to be associated
with me so like Purity yeah Purity as
well you want to come from a good place
you want to have good like morals and
stuff like that so it's not it's like if
you know one day you end up having to
meet their family and stuff their family
don't feel like they have anything to
like pick at you about like you've got
good morals you come from a good place
you know you've got yourself together
and they can see that as well then
that's what they're looking for
what about you um definitely men want
love 100
um loyalty
um they want peace they want you to be
their pieces so how can you give up
because I always hear women say that
like I want to be his peace but I never
hear any specifics
um it's in terms of like you know it
leaves the house but work stress got
stereotype stress
um and then you come home and then
you're probably moaning about something
that he he didn't call you today like I
bring peace to my partner and I'm not
just saying that but I I I know that
because when he come home and we're
together there's this
where he can just relax his shoulders
basically and not have to be this tough
or or watch his back or kind of be
like there's a lot of men have to carry
a lot basically so the fact that you can
be a shoulder to lean on listen to them
support them
um it's almost kind of like therapy but
not in that sort of big band want their
women to be therapists not therapists
I'm that way but men want to have
somebody that they can open up to as
much as they feel like they want to be
tough they want to be they want to have
their person and that and their partner
is that person where not judged not
feeling like they need to be something
that they have to be on the road in the
house that sort of thing
um and men want love they want genuine
wholehearted love
um because
you know it's that sort of thing you can
tell when a guy's in a good relationship
how they act and when they're in a bad
relationship it affects the whole world
around them as much as they might be
tough or not so that kind of deep
genuine
love is one of the things that they're
looking for because when guys are in the
young age and they're sleeping around
they're not looking for those
um
they're looking for family orientated
um a strong woman somebody like all
those things that they're looking for
when they want to settle down
actually I have one question do you
think women like men that are opening up
to them emotionally
um I think so yeah funny enough um I
know someone who
she appreciates that
um because you get to know the real
person when they open up
um in terms of partner because there's a
lot of things that shape a man you know
like family history
um what they went through childhood
adulthood like there's a lot of things
that shape them so when they open up to
a woman that's how they get the full
picture of a man for example my mom
always said when I started dating a man
can only act for so long so he might
approach her with this tough exterior
and then or he's chasing after something
and then
he can't act for that long and then you
kind of realize who that real person is
so yeah they appreciate when when open
up I don't think so I was gonna you know
no I don't there's studies that show
that like women like their husbands less
when they open up or cry to them and I
hear guys tell me all the time that like
they'll open up to like this is women
what we kind of do is we kind of like we
don't realize we're doing it but we
start to psychoanalyze men and it pisses
them off so like they'll say oh this
happened in my childhood or whatever
they'll open up to us and then we'll be
like every time we're in an argument
well it's because of his childhood and
it's like throwing it in their face
that's women leading from a different
angle there's this thing about listen to
understand rather than listen to respond
and people who that's that's basically
you throwing something back in someone's
face so there's women like that because
they're not I think it's common though
it is I don't even I don't even think it
always comes out of a like a place of
maliciousness I actually I think so no
well I mean for some women yeah but I've
heard girls do it and it's more of like
them explaining like why he's doing it
but guys don't want to hear that oh
they're trying to correct him basically
yeah yeah yeah but I genuinely think
that telling men to like open up to
women is bad advice overall
think like you're telling them to open
but like I think they should open up to
other men do you think so because I
don't I don't want I look at a guy I
want him to be my rock yeah I don't I
don't want a guy that's more emotional
than me but when he crumbles all of a
sudden it's like who's this person how
do I deal with it because I've never
seen this side I never saw it coming and
it's like whoa whoa whoa now he's really
soft and who is this I'm not saying
leave him the second you see any emotion
but I think by and large like the more
he does it the more likely you will
leave because you don't like do women
want weak men or do they want strong men
it doesn't make you weak to open up
I think there's a time and place and I
think I think as you said it depends on
what the woman's there for I think that
also plays a part because sometimes you
know when you're in a girl chat or I
feel like sometimes it does stem from I
wouldn't say actually it stems from any
age range of women or anything I think
it's off of perspective and her like you
said you want your mind to be but nine
times out of ten I do feel like if a man
opens up or he gets emotional I feel
like if you've not been together for a
very long period of time or it's quite
new women tend to go yeah but I don't
actually know why he opened up to me
like why is he acting better soft or
like it's just a bit like what do I do
do you know what I mean a lot of women
do get turned off by that kind of stuff
yeah of course yeah that's why it is
always better to open up with your boys
yeah and sometimes your boys just can't
support you like that yeah not always or
even reach out to a coach or a mentor an
expert in that field I'm not even just
saying no but that's that's actually the
reason why I got into it but like um
yeah unfortunately let's admit that your
words do get used against you in an
argument
and women do sometimes tend to go to
that that because when they want to get
a reaction out of you they want to see
some emotion they will go to that soft
place so I always thought I meant just
yeah not not to open up in front of your
girl and I think it goes back to like
all them like old time sayings you know
like
you treat him and mean keep him Keen so
it's like that's what women like kind of
sometimes that chase and that play with
men I feel like they don't always like
what they want sometimes they like to be
put in their place they're like a man to
be able to know he can do that well and
I think it also goes back to like women
reproduce with aggressive men you know
that um felon violent felons have more
children than people that don't have a
criminal history wow not to do with
grape though I mean that sounds a little
sus that they have a violent history and
then they have more children look at
what happened to Ted Bundy when he was
in prison I know that I feel like that's
a wild exception in general no it's not
an exception if you look at if you take
the percentage of men that reproduce
that are violent felons they reproduce
more than people without a criminal
history and when there's even like a
trend of women falling in love with
their captors or or pursuing those men
when they're in prison that's trauma
like that's trauma though it's Stockholm
syndrome is like pursuing your character
no I don't think it is I think it's
biology I'm not saying it's like a good
thing
but why because because historically
what what happened we were in tribes
right and what would happen you would be
with the strongest man because they
would kill your man and they would take
you I don't know so you had to like
learn how to beat fall in love with the
person that captured captured you if you
wanted to survive and reproduce just
like an anomaly here but like I could
not be with a man if he didn't open up
to me if he didn't have a soft side and
like if someone opens up to me early on
I take that as a positive sign that I've
made them feel comfortable I've never
ever ever judged someone for that and I
don't think that men should be trying to
be with the kind of women that would
judge them for that I agreed I would
never encourage my male friends to be
with a girl who would like snare at him
for crying yeah but I think by and large
like women lose respect for men the more
that they open up so I think it's like
from a feminine point of view where like
this is why they say women give bad
dating advice because across the board
women don't respect men that open up
more I think it depends on a lot of
factors like age and stuff like that
because I think maybe at 23 I would have
been like oh but no you mean at 45 he's
had children he's had trauma are you
gonna have people come with more stuff
and I'm more like 360 now and I would be
able to deal with it much more now than
I would be I wouldn't judge a man for
opening up to me now I mean yeah you
might not think you would no I really
don't think no but there's there's
studies that show that women lose
respect for men the more they cry the
more they like that's one way that men
open up is still a nice fragment of
society right it's across the board
they've done multiple studies with
multiple different women in multiple
regions because think about it like we
don't we don't want a guy that's crying
every day not every day but like
something traumatic's happened to him
his dad's died you want him crying but
see this is what this is the thing
though like every time I bring up this
example that's always what women say
it's like when his dad died that's
extreme
overall you still want a strong man you
don't want a guy that's crying every day
every day every day and we're doing like
once like there's a again there's a
spectrum okay so how often can he cry
like when the way often like when
something traumatic happens okay so how
often what if it's once a week you
staying no okay I would say I feel like
it I mean if it was going through a bad
patch or something and he's got
depression and like then again it's
different so three years he's depressed
every week he's crying that's gonna be
tough but see that's that's my point but
if I was crying every day for three
years that's gonna be tough it's not big
no girls cry once a month if you know
what I mean yeah but that's not every
day for three years
no it depends on your preference now
you're right there's some women that put
up with more and there's some that put
up with less but if you're advising men
why would you tell them to do something
that most women don't like I don't want
them to be with most women though I'd
want them to be with someone who's going
to emotionally support them and love
them like unconditionally
women don't love unconditionally they
love under conditioning 100 yeah come on
if your guy was unemployed for 10 years
you're staying no not working sitting on
the couch it's
situational when you know about somebody
but that's the point see you you
wouldn't but you would it like if
something happened my boyfriend if my
boyfriend got cancer and couldn't work
and he was ill for 10 years would I
leave him absolutely not not in a
million years I would say and I'd
support him but I wasn't talking about
the exception I'm talking about the rule
and one of the number one indicators of
divorce is financial
yeah because and women and actually one
out of six divorces women are spiteful
and wreck men in court
financially wrecked that means they
don't give them access to the children
and they also financially ruined them
one out of every six divorces yeah but
most men don't it's only like 20 of men
try to get access to their children why
I don't know why because they feel like
it's not a fair fight so they just don't
bother but why would you not fight if I
had lost control I don't have children
but if I lost my children I'd fight for
them I wouldn't be okay like I'll tell
you I'll tell you I'll tell you why they
don't fight so um I interviewed and I'm
doing a documentary on this so I
actually have spoken like I just did one
today
um
so basically what a girl can do is she
can put it's a restraining order I
forgot what you you guys non-molestation
order yeah so so one call right she can
put in a non-molestation order and say
he abused her and by the way she's
incentivized to say this so she gets
Free Housing if she says that he abused
her and free um lawyers
so one call he's out of his house
because he can't stay in the house he he
still has to pay the mortgage on and now
he doesn't get a court date for a year
so it takes him a year six months to a
year to even see his kid that she's not
letting him see and he can't even
legally go and try to see the kid Okay
then if he wants to so she gets free
lawyers and by the way these women's
shelters they know exactly what to say
so he cannot get access to the kids okay
um and so on top of that and this is
this women can do this too or men can do
this too but they're not typically the
first ones who file women file 80 of the
time 90 of their college educated so on
top of that if he wants to fight in
courteous to spend twenty to thirty
thousand dollars or pounds here would
your children not be well okay okay okay
I'll get to it so the average guy makes
what 35 000 pounds so now he's in all
this debt trying to get his kids okay so
he goes to court and there's only a 10
chance of him winning
ten percent of the time so now he's just
and on top of that he's still paying the
mortgage on his house and on top of that
he he's now on child support so he's
probably paying like three four hundred
bucks a month on top of maybe a fifteen
hundred dollar a month mortgage so
that's almost two grand okay he's paying
a month and then he's got the court fees
this is where a lot of men kill
themselves yeah because they can't see
their kids there's only a 10 chance
they'll get primary custody he could go
through the whole thing and probably and
if he's lucky he gets six days a month
with his kid and she can do it all over
again with one call but if you take that
back to the beginning to get a non-mole
in the first place you need probable
cause he was violent no you don't no
yeah no you don't
you don't need any evidence there I know
a girl that got Free Housing and there
was no man that did anything like she
didn't have a boyfriend and she just
said that you don't need any evidence or
proof because the differences in family
court it's not based off of evidence
it's based off of a balance of abilities
and typically when women cry and say
they were abused the judge is just going
to believe her because again in family
court you don't need evidence where in
Criminal Court you do so the question is
why aren't these women in criminal court
now what percent of cases did the women
actually in in the women's shelters what
percent of cases did the women actually
file Criminal Court where Like a Man
actually got a jury a trial all about
what percent of cases do you think there
is well clearly if that system is
allowing them to lie then they they
won't while they're going for criminal
right but I'm saying so like if someone
punches you in the face most likely
you're gonna go to court right yeah
right you would think right so what what
percent out of 10 women in these women's
shelters what percent of them actually
went to Criminal Court
it's higher than you say it's like 15 to
20 so 80 of cases there's no evidence
and with one phone call she takes away
as kids and financially ruins him and
now he he's saying on top of the child
support he's paying on top of the the um
restraining order on top of all of these
fees on top of arguing at the mother for
a year he needs to fight for his kids
and pay 20 to 30 000 pounds for a 10
outcome do you know what if I was a guy
I wouldn't do it I wouldn't you wouldn't
I think there's men that would go to the
ends of the Earth for their children but
I think there's a lot of men that don't
I I think that's easy to say in a place
of privilege but if you're making he at
this point most of the men are homeless
and on top of that their entire
Community thinks they're an abuser with
no evidence but are they homeless though
because you've said two things like the
woman's in the house and he's paying the
mortgage or is she in a woman shelter
which which one no no they go sorry they
go to the women's
um it's not women's shelter it's like a
women's uh charity to help Refugee
there's a name for it but it's like it's
a women's group basically yeah and so
she's in the house he's officially
homeless and now he's paying two grand a
month and one guy interviewed it was
actually the saddest interview he had um
three kids and he was a mile away and he
couldn't see them
um he was a mile away from them and he
this man was fighting but he lost his
job because he worked in electricity and
imagine if you're homeless and you can't
see your kids and now like mentally how
are you going to do that yeah and so
it's like it's like we have this
narrative and a lot of like feminists
honestly push this narrative where it's
like men need to be more men need to do
more why when the systems are against
them and he could go through all of that
not see his kid for a year one more
phone call she can just do it again and
sign him up for another year
and you know I think how long has he
expected to do that until he how long
has he expected to financially ruin
himself the average guy makes 35 000 a
year that costs more than thirty
thousand what is he supposed to do he
doesn't have the money
I think we're preparing I think going
back to what you said in terms of when
you were saying you'd want you'd push
your female friends to support men and
you'd want your male friends to go for
someone that does do that I think it's
kind of Devil's advocating what you're
saying reality is is that you have to
prepare the men around you for what can
happen which is that and I think there's
a fine line between having an opinion
off of what you would do and what
actually happens in society and that's
one out of six divorces that that
happens and they factor in um like women
that do it for like a good reason right
like maybe he actually was abusive or so
so they take out those but it's one in
six divorces
[Music]
um
so
it's really depressing it's actually
really sad I'm going to read super chats
for a second
um guys
make sure you like the video and
subscribe to the channel a thousand
likes and we will open up the chat also
guys
um make sure that you are signing up for
a memberships to be a part of the live
chat tonight
um also wait let me
okay I think we just have a couple
um Sam G I would want my man to open up
we can't use it against him if we are
only complaining and being weak that's
different Manny F men don't want you to
open up because women will use it
against you and in the end temporary
feeling to justify permanent decisions
um Johnny Yelp I'm reaching out to men
is the way to go they can relate
interracial relationships men want a
woman that brings 100 femininity which
equals submission submission respect
peace love food and sex lots and lots of
sex men want a woman that brings 100
femininity with equal you said the same
thing three times okay
[Laughter]
um young got a good head on her
shoulders for the most part men want
respect and Trust if a man feels like
you don't respect trust or love them
they will treat you as cold as ice um
walks Game Central if a man makes money
you need to stay in the house at that
level he wants influence you can provide
doing charity connections only part-time
um zurer lost single mothers are
recreational will use only waksa games
most wealth is old with older men jobs
make you look jobs you look down on make
more money the plumber makes 80k and
more the teacher makes 40K put away your
preferences Carlos men create most
things I had the same thought silly
sausage I'm honestly it's so sad to hear
that you think men should clean up the
clean up the consequences of your own
actions lives and deceptions if you had
a baby you should go to jail the baby's
bad life after that is your fault Bane
Metra money-minded girls are for are in
for a rude awakening later in life the
original back in gaming yes
birth control was under Congressional
scrutiny in 2019 when they found there
were adverse effects yet doctors were
paid to stay quiet I watched my mom go
through this before baby shut down yes
lying about being on birth control is
coercion and should be punished stop
trapping men that's the point y'all trap
men when you do that I'm gonna refresh
it real quick guys make sure you like
the video that is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these shows
um okay I read all of these
going back to the actually I'm curious
because I meant to ask you this earlier
out of the answers that everyone gave
for what men want
what do you feel like we got right and
what do you feel like we got wrong
uh the main ones that you got right is
definitely low tea
peace
key
um someone that looks after themselves
is also key and I think you actually
said someone that's fun that kind of
keeps you young I know somebody said
that
um but yeah those are definitely the
ones that you guys got right
um I'm trying to think of the ones that
you got wrong
or some of the other ones they're all
perfect answers they were all quite
solid answers to be fair there wasn't
anything that screamed out of me I
thought of course you know so no here
pretty good answers
okay
um so this article discusses a study
that found women who take hormonal
contraceptives prefer men with less
masculine features such as a softer
jawline and smaller brow ridges compared
to women who are not taking
contraceptions contraceptives the
preference may be due to the way
hormonal contraceptives affect a woman's
hormones and the type of partner she
sleeps with during her menstrual cycles
this study suggests that the use of
hormonal contraceptive contraceptives
May alter women's preferences for mates
which could have implications for
attraction and relationship outcomes AKA
she meets a man while on the pill gets
married decides to have a child and gets
off the pill
to have a baby only to become disgusted
with her partner leading to divorce and
infidelity
um how do you think a woman's natural
menstrual cycle affects her attraction
to masculine versus feminine facial
features
is there different types of men that
you're attracted to based on like where
you are in your cycle I mean I think
definitely
you can it's not about different facial
features but when you are ovulating and
you're ready to procreate I think you
definitely there's definitely
I find men more attractive like walking
down the street you'd be like I'd walk
down the same street twice and if I'm
ovulating I wouldn't see anything it
takes you on a date he should like try
yeah yeah check my cycle but I don't
think it but I've not noted I mean it's
quite nuanced isn't it to know what kind
of menu have you ever met a guy and not
found him attractive but then found him
attractive later
she's like she's like couldn't be me it
couldn't be me
I mean I know like people grow on you
but I think there has to be in initials
spark of something yeah have you ever
heard a guy make it out of the friend
zone
yeah I've had guys that I've dated that
then have gone into the friend zone but
not the other way around what about you
um are you always attracted to the same
guy or does your type change
I wouldn't say my type changes off of my
hormonal State I think it would maybe
just change off of maybe experiences or
things I might see other people go
through or I don't know like stuff like
that but I wouldn't say it changes I
feel for like my hormonal State I think
my level of attraction to anyone might
change but my type doesn't change do you
prefer more masculine features or more
of a pretty boy
yeah I like a pretty boy pretty boy yeah
I don't know about them actually I'm
curious because you're you you said
you're on birth control yeah uh what
pretty boy or masculine I was gonna say
masculine masculine and you're not okay
I'm just I'm just curious masculine or
Pretty Boy Pretty Boy Pretty Boy okay
masculine masculine I'm not I did it
both I'm not very like looks oriented
okay in general it's money first well
people can grow on me I I've I've
definitely date people I've not been
attracted to initially yeah how did that
go fine like with my my boyfriend now I
didn't know what he looked like when we
start talking really how uh because he
was just somebody that messaged me and I
didn't he didn't know any pictures I
didn't know anything about it so he
messaged you on Instagram I'm guessing
I'm like through my Discord because I do
twitch okay
um so like I started speaking to him
through them and we just got talking for
like a week we had phone calls and I
didn't know who looked like
um and like that's a cute story yeah I'm
very attracted to him but like if I saw
him walking down the street would I like
be like oh my gosh this man has drop
dead gorgeous maybe not I don't know
like that's hard to say because I didn't
know but like I was instantly attracted
him from when I met him because I had
all this like build up of like getting
to know him but yeah I've definitely
dated man I've not been like initially
attracted to and then formed attraction
based on how we get on and the things
we're doing who here has had a guy make
it out of the friend zone that you
weren't attracted to raise your hand so
you yes right I'm guessing yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay
okay so one for five
okay so so I know odds odds for a guy
it's not good if he's in the friend zone
um what about you have you ever made it
out of the friend zone I'm not even
trying to be arrogant I'm not a friend
[Laughter]
really every girl you pursued has been
into you
no like don't get me wrong do you know
what the ones the one example I can
think of I'm not saying this obviously
I've obviously gone up to a gun she
hasn't fancied me or whatever but like
the one example stay there you just yeah
I just move on I say friend I've
respectfully move on but I remember one
girl I got with and um
ah this is a bit of a wild story but she
wanted me to be more aggressive
and I was like do you know what that's
just not me that's not what I'm into and
she actually lost attraction for me
because of that
[Music]
um so yeah that's that's my my one story
that's weird no I think I think that's
more common than you think I think
there's a cup I've dated a couple of
girls that said some wild stuff and I've
been like well no I don't really want to
go that way because of all the things
that you kind of said like if something
goes wrong further down the line yeah
and they you know they they say
something against you you could be in
deep water so
um yes well that's the I mean I had a
male um only fans model on here and you
know what he said his number one request
was guess
from women because he had women people
watching him that she doesn't post her
body online no no like for for Hughes
and only fans model so women requested
something of him like for private video
or like shaking I don't know abs and
like sauce or something I have some
sauce you think choking what do you what
do you think it was
I don't know like
oh what's that thing called when that
they're very aggressive like with toys
what like BDSM
close you're getting closer and closer
what do you think I have the words I can
see it and I can't say it but it's just
that kind of I think that tantric way of
like a dark room or things like that
like that type of what do you think it
was but he's on his own in a room it's
like the situation no he works with
other people also like spanking or
something then
grape great yeah that's what that's what
I wanted to say what's the two two very
pretty girls that I dated Philly said
that was a fantasy
wow I mean what what's the what's the
number one like woman sexual book 50
Shades of Gray yeah I mean I've never
read it I've just heard
yeah yeah but it goes back to like we
always needed men to protect us so if a
guy's aggressive he would have been able
to protect us back in the day
so there's like there's something
biological there you don't you don't
just just because we're in a more modern
society you don't get rid of our
biological Roots
but do you think that was very sad
though yeah you think it's sad yeah I do
think it's that and like also like I
should to be totally honest I was part
of a demographic of women that when I
was younger I thought that I was
supposed to want those things and it was
until I got a little bit older that I
was like oh I like don't have to have
violent sex like I can just say why did
you think you were supposed to want it
because of corn
because of all the corn that I'd seen in
my life I thought like women are
supposed to have a documents like
violence really I remember seeing like a
form of documentary with parents coming
out about corn saying that what is
exposed on the internet they're scared
for their kids to grow up and see
because they couldn't they would never
want their kids to experience yeah and
it's almost like it's pushed you to
think that is okay for a man to do that
or if that is okay to do that without
asking a question and I think that's the
borderline of men as well I think it's
hard with men and women because I mean
obviously I've got two brothers and you
know I have cousins and stuff and I I
always say like sometimes actually just
let a woman show that she wants you so
there's no there's no question of you
didn't ask or I don't know if I was
emotionally ready and I'll say where I
say we're quite more emotional we've met
like than men so I feel like sometimes
we might think we want something until
it happens and sometimes when you're
taking more baby steps in a process we
have more time to back out and I think
if you're not given that time or a man
doesn't allow you to have that emotional
moment sometimes the lines can be
blurred and I think women that don't
want to take accountability for saying
no to things or to maybe be a bit more
open about things then push that
um anger or like regret feeling onto the
man which then turns into grape do you
see what I mean and I think there's a
finite they regret the sex that they had
or whatever they did and then they turn
it into great 100 and I think that you
know
how can I put it like they do that
because they don't like the fact that
they angry at themselves and I guess we
they're not taking accountability for
that and it goes back to society where
women are pushed to kind of be in that
bubble of being okay with not doing that
and it is wrong I mean did you hear that
case in the U.S there was a guy who um
the girl accused him of grape and then
there there was footage that came out of
her pulling him back to the dorm and her
pulling him in to kiss her and he still
got kicked out of school wow this is the
way that the world's going and it's
scary and that's going back to your
point that's why I can understand why
people don't even want to have kids
anymore because
then this is the reason why as well men
feel like they can't even speak about
things because when they do you're
misogynistic you're controlling
patriarchy all of these buzzwords and
yeah men don't feel like they could even
say at their own Point yeah anymore
without being looked at a certain way I
do think that when you talk about like
false great accusations just to throw
out the other side of that it's just
it's such a small issue and I understand
that when it does happen to somebody it
totally ruins their life and that
Minority of people like they are ruined
they get kicked out of University they
lose all their friends it is awful but
it's such a minority when you look at
like great cases in general how many
actually go to trial and then how many
actually like the person goes to prison
over it but it's just it's so hard to
prove especially if your partner does it
to you there's no proof you can't prove
it but that also in between going to
trial in between actually
was it innocent until proven guilty it's
actually you're guilty until proven
innocent well you have the court of
public opinion yeah I totally agree with
you but I just think that that's such a
minority I don't know any woman that's
accused a man of grape do you yeah I
know really I know someone that that's
happened to what if he's a school
teacher what if he's a school teacher
you know this world is so small all it
takes is for the wrong person to hear
the wrong thing and it can ruin someone
and he needs to spend it with full pay
for a period of time it's not as the
smallest issue as you think I hear what
you're saying like how many like
actually make it to court but then
you've got to remember that social media
is everything now and you've got to
remember as well with women that have
experienced that or they've got a friend
that's experience that or women kind of
you know their group things in a way
like they will all you know jump in the
band if they feel like a woman's being
abused quite rightly but in certain
circumstances if it is a false
allegation that guy's life is ruined his
reputation is ruined just by someone
saying
I'm just curious
who here knows someone that was falsely
accused of grape or assault or something
that you personally know and you believe
was false
so two three so this is one two three
four five six seven so out of seven
people that I don't know there's three
you know you don't think that's a big
problem massive problem massive I think
that's really hard though because I
don't know the people that you know I
don't know if you like if somebody
accused somebody I was very very close
to you of great if somebody accused my
brother there was nothing in me that
would ever think that my brother would
do that does that mean that I know a
hundred percent no you never know you
know anything though that's that's like
saying people about it exactly death row
you know there's a lot of people that
have been sentenced to things they
should never ever they have been to
court and they've been dealt with by a
judge these are people that often
haven't I'm guessing most of these
things have sometimes being dealt with
by a judge doesn't also mean that it's
fair and it as it actually half the time
isn't right but it's based on evidence
but we just went over that it's not in
family corn and I I talked to these men
like they've had their entire reputation
ruined like one guy even his whole
family thought that he did it like she
convinced him them that he did it
do you not think that that's odd though
if I was accused of something heinous I
think my family would believe I did it
and because I didn't you know no because
I think a lot of times when women cry
people believe them
um I think that if she really that
really happened to her I think she would
have went to court and I think you
should go to court that's a dangerous
mindset to have that there's a lot of
people that don't go to court for a lot
of reasons
um extremely traumatic thing well I I
think that you shouldn't be speaking
about something publicly that that a guy
has not had a chance to defend himself I
think that's not fair I I think if if
you're gonna accuse me of a crime and go
around saying that I committed a crime I
should have the right to go to court and
defend myself but the problem is women
will accuse men of things ruin their
jobs ruin their reputation and it's all
it's all from family court or the court
of public opinion neither of which that
he gets a fair trial but then he can do
what joined up did and defamation too
like I think I think you make it you
know and you're right Johnny Depp was
able to do that but you even a man with
money status and fame she still ruined
his life for a couple years what what
happens to the average guy the average
guy can't afford to do that yeah you
know how expensive it is and I know
because I'm I'm
there's some people some of y'all can
get it um
but I know it I know because like I'm
going to court with certain people so
it's like it's like it's expensive so if
a guy's making 40 000 a year and his
ex-wife just financed he's now homeless
what he's going to go to court to defend
himself how and remember everyone lacks
the pointer finger men or women it's
just human nature no one likes to take
responsibility for actions it's just the
natural thing to do right yeah but the
difference is that women can get away
with it where men can't because there's
no consequence so if there's a shitty if
both genders are shitty but the women
can get away with it what what are the
Men supposed to do well can I ask a
question I know we did the question do
we know anyone that's been accused of do
we can we do the same thing do we know
or know someone that was graped yeah go
ahead
yeah I just wanted to know in the room
yeah
I don't know I have a question did you
did you automatically believe them
yeah yes yeah I did but they I think
that's part of the did they go to court
yeah they were too young to go to court
you know I think well great can happen
at any time in your life right so I
think I actually do think that's like
how I I agree with you like I think when
they're younger they usually don't yeah
and I think sometimes you're actually so
young well it kind of turns into a
different type of um category of grape
but I think you're too young to even
understand what is actually even
happening to you know make that decision
and agree yeah but then I do sometimes I
think when you hear things as you grow
up and you people don't come out of
things for 30 years and sometimes people
have even passed and whatever by the
time you know about something it's like
with the people around them when you
said why was it not spoken about because
I mean I can't sit here I've never gone
through something like that but there
was a time when I think I was about 11
years old
um my mom used to like she loves taking
lots of pantomime it's really cool so he
used to go to pan tonight every
Christmas and one year we went to
pantomime we went to Nando's after it
was like me my sister her partner's
brother and stuff and my brother and
then I just took like me my
brother-in-law and my brother down like
to the toilet I made sure they like I
didn't go in the toilet but I made sure
they locked themselves together in the
toilet and then I went to the toilet and
the guy that was in the toilet when I
watched them go in followed me out
followed me into the women's toilet and
as God is my witness I'm a good fearing
woman there was 12 girls in there
getting ready to go on a night out doing
their makeup and I said thank the Lord I
for Rose I didn't know what I was gonna
do but I knew I'd do something in the
end but like in that moment I do
understand sometimes why women don't
come out of it straight away because I
could never imagine what would have
happened if them 12 girls went in the
toilet but again at that age the first
thing I did was go to my mum yeah that
was going to be my question because if
they're younger like why didn't they go
to their parents yeah because I went
straight to my mom my mom was ready you
know I ain't gonna say nothing on this
but like you know my mum was ready to
rock someone bro you know I mean like
she was like what's going like she even
went to the girls and asked did you see
that and they said we saw because they
asked me UK and I said I'm fine and then
I just didn't even bother going toilet I
just grabbed my brother and stuff and
ran upstairs to my mum and so I think
the question is about consent like
what's like as a mum and I've got two
daughters like how do I teach them about
the consent like what where the line is
you know because when I grew up there
wasn't like this wasn't a thing really
it wasn't talking the consent thing
wasn't talked about so like how far do
you go with a guy when it's you're like
and then you can't go any like there's
no way of stopping and then you regret
it but is that that or like I think if
you regret isn't you can't say it's not
a consent just because you regret it no
no that's not exactly but I'm that's
like I think a lot of times girls
confuse like a guy will be pushy but
they'll they'll confuse that with grape
but like I don't think so that's why
where's the consent like how do we teach
children too like no no stop yeah no no
no stop it's I think it's really clear
yeah I think we're now trying to make it
really confusing yeah and we're over
complicating the issue no stop no I
don't feel like it done
I think that takes for a woman if you're
like rolling around with a guy in bed
like coming up
in that situation that's what I'm saying
about what situation like what how far
do you have to go well I just like why
are you bringing a guy to your apartment
late at night if you don't want to sleep
with him okay but
it yeah and then you get to that
position and it's harder to say no at
that position so but as a parent I think
from what I've taken from my parents I
think what always gave me confidence in
my decision was having that wisdom from
them and I think in nowadays I think
because of the way the world is parents
are so afraid of letting their children
know and then what happens is the world
then makes your kids in terms of it's
the world that's now teaching them so
one thing I think I would say is with
your daughters is give them that wisdom
I think when I used to go on guide trips
to like you know campsites and stuff Mum
would be like stay with the group if
someone touches you it is wrong tell
someone so when you've got someone
enforcing it my mom wasn't afraid to
open me and my siblings up to things
that we can encounter and I think it's
you judging what age you feel
comfortable doing that with I'm trying
to judge before that happens so that
they have that confidence and they go
back to that time when mommy told me
this or daddy told me now and it's like
just reinforcing it it's not like he
comes in at like 14 you have the
conversation it's like empowering them
from the get from the get-go I agree
that they have that choice about any
decision I always I always wonder about
this because I I had a little different
background I went to Catholic school so
we had no sex ed none of that [__] you
know and I never even really had like a
sex talk really with my parents but I
just I don't know I just knew you could
tell people no I don't know was that
confusing to people but would you say
religion gives you a form of discipline
to understand what's right from wrong
side yeah no I agree I do think because
I was I was pretty religious when I was
younger so I I do think that deterred
some of that stuff but I think that
encouraged you and you've got that
confidence in I think having Something
to Believe In or that you know
definitely gives you that confidence to
in other situations move them skills
over and make them transferable would
you ever
um tell your daughters to wait till they
were married
no no no you don't think that would
result in like better outcomes for them
because you know because a lot of these
situations are just from you know dating
right but if you're married then
but if you've empowered them and they're
strong individuals who can make their
own decisions I don't have to wait till
marriage I think it's a bit of a I mean
you don't want to get married and then
find out that there's no sexual
compatibility for that but how would you
know if you've never had sex with anyone
else how would you know
[Music]
um
yeah I think I wouldn't tell my kids to
do something I've not done yeah because
I don't know that experience so I can't
advise them on something that I don't
know the outcome of and that would make
me feel uneasy I can only advise them on
what I know or what someone else has
told me to say do you think do you think
it's better for girls to sleep with
multiple men or less men less men so
then so then why wouldn't you encourage
them to wait that's not celibacy though
sleeping with less men like being
sensible about your sexual partners and
being completely celibate until marriage
are two different things it's the best
outcomes for women it doesn't learn
though it's proven time and time again
the celibacy doesn't work no that's
that's not right if um if you're a
virgin on your wedding night you have an
80 chance of a happy marriage it drops
down to 20 if you have more than five
Partners now some people don't like that
study so there's ones that are it's like
a 10 to 15 difference but the trend is
still the same when you're a virgin on
your wedding night you have the best
outcomes but when I say it doesn't work
I don't mean it in terms of outcomes of
your marriage I mean kids don't stick to
it kids are gonna have sex oh yeah I
mean when you're putting them I mean
most people here were on birth control
from like 16 to 18 years old so when
you're enabling them to make bad
decisions of course they're going to
make more of them but if you give them
if you don't give them birth control
they're still gonna have sex I disagree
I went to Catholic school we had no teen
pregnancies and we had no sex said none
of that stuff we had none I had like 200
people and I know I know some people
like the Catholic schools are different
out here I don't know yeah and again I
think social media I think it's become
such a strong influence I think things
that you back in the day I'd say that
you wanted to hold back from the from
your kids you could because you knew it
was going to be at a later stage that
they would be exposed to this where now
social media is such a strong current
it's so strong I would want my kids to
be a lot more aware a lot sooner than
maybe I was even aware of things because
I you know my sisters went on social
media like that like you know what I
mean so it's like now you know my niece
my nieces they play on tablets they do
all these things look at Kim Kardashian
she needed out a heart attack on the
series because her children that he saw
Elite of her you know thing tape that
was like she was freaking out you know
so you know this whole internet thing is
so big do you guys think it's selfish to
put promiscuous things on the internet
knowing that you want to have kids later
yeah yeah yeah no very yeah that's it
yeah who said who said no I said no why
because you're your own human being and
I think that you should shelter your
children from that until they're of age
to understand that you are an adult
that's made your own choices
um and that they are an adult and they
can make their own choices you don't
think the family comes before you
because that just sounds like me me me
I'm my own person but a family's
supposed to be one unit it's so
difficult though to make those decisions
before you're a mother because it does
change like you can regret you can
change there are women who I think are
fantastic mothers that have been corn
stars that have been prostitutes that
can move on get married have kids and
just have a normal life I like Shannon
Rose on YouTube she's a big ex-con so I
think she's a great mother it's sad to
say that they can't be a great mother
but we're talking about the decision
with the decision like why would you put
something on the Internet when you have
kids later you might not want children
then but even so it's like if I don't
think so that's why I said knowing
you're going to have kids later I didn't
say you don't want kids I don't think
that you should live your entire life of
like oh what would my children think
like I just really I do I think you
should have a legacy that you'd be proud
of that you want your kids to see I
don't think that that defines you though
I don't think posting some racy pictures
on the internet is what defines you
don't think your your actions define who
you are like your choices Your Life
Choices we see time and time again that
all these Tick Tock trains are blowing
like look how hot my mum was when she
was young you know like people don't
care they love seeing racy pictures of
their parents videos
of like their parents because their
parents look good like people look good
you go I mean that people are not just
attractive now they've been attractive
yeah but like if you're going around and
you're posting pictures of yourself
naked on the internet and stuff like
that like and you know you want kids
later you gotta remember everything
comes around 360. do you want your kids
to look at you after they've seen you so
modest your whole life and then they've
seen you just posting yourself and
flaunting yourself on the internet like
you've got no respect for yourself like
I just it doesn't set a good example
especially if it's something you can't
take off okay what do you think it's
about go ahead
I think you're just an adult that can
make your decisions again Trisha Paytas
another example she has a terrible
history on the internet she's done
everything wrong you could possibly do
but everything I see of her as a mother
I think she's fantastic I think she's a
great mother I think that her children
was bipolar disorder she's got
borderline personality girl girl how do
you know if she's a good mother
literally
what we see on social media yeah but are
the best Mothers putting their kids on
social media is that a wise thing to do
I understand the point that you're
making but all I can do is use the
examples that I see in the media because
I don't know anyone in my personal life
that's done corn and then gone on to
have children which is why I have to use
those examples
um but what I would say is that like I
think it's important to shelter your
children from a period of time and then
when they're old enough have an adult
conversation of being like Mom did this
here it is you know like just with the
internet you can't you don't have that
you don't have a choice like some kid in
the playground when they're eight years
old is gonna find it and someone that
you don't have that ownership of the of
the entire web like and I'm not saying
I'm one way or the other but you can't
say that I'm gonna just wait until
they're 16 years old and then it's all
gonna be fine because they'll find out
way before I think the main point is it
doesn't make you a bad mother I think
that's wild to say that during Quan
makes you a bad mother it's more a case
of just know that all your actions have
consequences yeah and I think your kids
reap that consequence but yeah but
usually every time someone has that sort
of past and they have kids it's almost
as if they want a clean State and they
want to erase it for example Blac Chyna
is trying to do that yeah Kim Kardashian
is trying to do that so it just comes I
think it's just something about
motherhood and you know having your own
kids that you don't want them to see
what you had to do or that choice that
you made because at that time you're
just doing what kind of works for your
lifestyle but once you become a mother
and you're trying to set an example
that's where where it comes in where
you're like actually I don't want my
kids to see that because one you don't
want your kids to follow in those sort
of footsteps you know sorry no it's just
nothing to say that they're bad parents
but it's just a proven you know opinion
that I think they're worse parents
do you think so yeah yeah I do I think
you're you're probably uh balanced
surprise if I had to guess you're
probably a worse parent if you did corn
than the people that didn't most likely
if I had to guess if I had to like bet
on it I would probably bet on the one do
you think they're just gonna be trying
to prove exactly no I think that people
that make those decisions think about
themselves before their future families
and I think a lot of those people are
selfish and they want a quick they want
a quick out
um they want quick money as opposed to
doing things the hard way or the right
way yeah I don't disagree with that but
also you've got the you're talking about
future children that you may never have
and you may not be able to have so
you're living your life for 30 years of
your life of for these imaginary
children that you could never have I
don't hold yourself I think the best
Mothers wanted to be mothers from a
young age so if I had to pick yeah if I
had to pick the the women typically that
make the best Mothers like if I had an A
plus you wanted that from a young age
and that's all they wanted and I think
being a parent I think the bottom and
top line of being a great parent is
being selfless yeah and I think you know
that's one of the hardest traits I want
um any human
that can actually do because being so
you you're naturally selfish anyway you
know you go out to get money for
yourself well obviously it's for the
family and stuff but it's for you to
also look after yourself do certain
things and whatever so we're naturally
selfish I think mastering you know the
trait of being selfless is what makes
you a good mother a good mother a good
father trust me that comes naturally
like as soon as you have children but
their lips I think you have to try and
be selfless beforehand and I think like
you said you might you I I could be
preparing for kids God forbid that I
could never have but I've got nieces
coming up behind me I've got women
coming up behind me that I also have a
duty that I feel to influence and I
don't want to influence them in the
wrong way and I don't want people on the
street word on the street is your
Auntie's doing X Y and Z I don't want my
nieces going through that you're
speaking or your parents or your
siblings like if I did corn tomorrow
like that's that's me if tomorrow I
started an only fans like I would be
thinking of myself over my family that's
so embarrassing to my whole family that
my mom went through all that labor for
me to go out and do that I don't think
so all of us here though are speaking
from a point of privilege where we have
a choice like we have a choice everyone
here has a job being a living we're fine
there are a lot of people coerced into
corn there are a lot of people that find
themselves trapped in it I think that
it's unfair to say that those people I
think it's perfectly Fair because men
are in the same situation and they don't
have an out they just go to McDonald's
it's not if the women don't want to go
to McDonald's that they choose to do all
they tend to join the Army but yeah
drill into Army is better than doing
that yeah like but that's the point
women women we have a choice and so if
they make the selfish Choice it's it's I
think we can assume they're more selfish
I mean women are trafficked every day
and then end up in corn and then we're
not talking about women that are
trafficking I think we're talking about
we're talking about we're talking about
women but like you keep going to an
exception and not the rule we're talking
about women that choose to do corn um
I'm not I'm not talking about women that
were trafficked yeah so do you think
women that have done that in their past
should
not have the privilege of having
children no I think
I think everyone should everyone should
have kids yeah everyone should have the
choice but you can't take away the
accountability of knowing that that
action was selfish and that you have to
take accountability for what your kids
are could go through and you've got to
take responsibility for that and at one
point in your life you might have to
apologize for that and I think that's
where women don't that's what we mean
don't do it's like no but they shouldn't
be going through this because of xyvid
and they shouldn't yeah that's just life
it's like I shouldn't have to always
have to think about locking my doors and
locking my windows if I leave my house
but I have to do why because I might not
come back to no you're not I'm going to
answer your question I think they're
women that have done of or corn should
be able to have children if they want
however I think that men should not get
them pregnant
yeah why would I tell a guy to pick her
when he could pick someone that doesn't
do it yeah like would you want your
brother to pick someone that did corn or
of or your son no no
no no
someone will always do it though so
that'll yeah yeah yeah and then also too
that that maybe comes from the part that
if you do corn then you're like like
you're written off as a woman that's
what you know like it's you know it's
like like people like what they like and
I just think that if that's the path
that you had to take whether it was your
choice or not then there's there just
has to be some accountability when you
do have kids and be like okay this was
me and can I just say when you said
certain choice I think you know when it
even comes to men that say you know you
don't want to work in McDonald's
do whatever it is you want to do most of
these things normally stem from which is
you want more money to do more things
that are actually not substantial
they're not things that you need they're
things that you want so ultimately that
choice isn't coming from a place of need
it's coming from a place of one you
don't want to work in McDonald's because
you don't want to wear Primark you don't
want to work in McDonald's because you
don't want to always have to eat let's
say corned beef and rice you want to be
going fat crab then you want to be doing
St okay like what what is the reasons
for you making these choices is it for a
reasonable sacrifice or is it because
it's just selfish again for the for the
reasons of your own well-being to be
heightened most people in corn aren't
earning big money though that's a small
percentage of people that are earning
big bucks do people go into corn to make
little money is that their intention
nobody goes into any job to make little
money okay so it's still her point is
still the same you do it for a quick
money
[Music]
just because just because you're bad at
it like you're still wearing for the
same attention
I'll be so embarrassed if I started an
elephant but nobody bought it like do
you think people go to start a lying to
make you know but one thing guys don't
go to start a line or do certain things
to be making the same wage yeah as a man
that's only 30k I think from a guy point
of view as I said like I don't think it
writes you off as a woman as you said
there's always going to be men that do
go for go for that especially if they
think the girl is beautiful and
everything like that they'll still go
there but I think it's just I think
where it only just winds me up is you
know like Mia Khalifa for example
goes into corn
make loads of money does really well
besides it's not for her and then it's
like well
no one should be judging me for what
I've done and that's just the world that
we live in she didn't make loads of
money that's why she's annoyed she
didn't know she did no she still did do
very well no there's a number one she
was the number one yeah and she didn't
get the money for it she got a small pay
for what she did initially this is the
whole thing that's why she's on social
media speaking out against how much did
she make I think it was like 10 000
pounds it's more than that no I'm pretty
sure it was and then she said the
production company took everything else
because that was that was like the first
Tick Tock I saw from her was her talking
about how like she was taken advantage
of
taking advantage oh come on she was not
taken advantage of I mean she's a very
young girl and she did some extremely
regrets she was like what 18. I don't
know probably my in my first job at Uni
I took a job very very silly because it
was very it's quite in my home it was
like a recruitment job for like 16 500
pounds
I could sit there and say that I was
taken advantage of no I was just silly I
made a very stupid and dumb choice and
it is what it is I learned from it like
come on we all have to be accountable
for our choices I can't just say oh
because she was a young girl come on I
think you're underestimating how
manipulative these industries are but
you should get into it she chose to get
into it she wanted to make money she
made money she's upset about the amount
she made cool but she wanted to make
that money anyway so regardless whether
she made 20 pounds or 100K like and even
and even if you just saw the stats there
as well even if she made ten thousand
which I know it was more than that but
let's say it was ten thousand that's a
lot of money for a girl that age
literally I'm not saying that she didn't
get ripped off by the production company
I agree with you on that but that's
still a substantial amount of money I
don't think that's a lot of money for
for what you're doing and the fact that
you then can't go back and it's the same
with like um Lana Rhodes that's another
one that speaks out constantly about how
she was coerced into doing more and more
and more and she's is constantly told by
these production companies we've done it
now you can't get back you've done that
you can't go back but do you see the
tendency these stories it's all time she
was meant to drink her own sick she
chose to drink her own she just like
like why do we say coerced when it's a
choice you chose something this is the
consequence nobody's gonna respect you
ever and why did the crazy thing is
these corn Stars they still use their
corn names if you're so ashamed why do
you still have your core name go back to
your legal name that's the only way that
she can make money now is by influencing
essentially but she has so she still
makes money off her name
McDonald's is hiring she could go to
McDonald's she just wants the lifestyle
and the attention or she could change
make money off of changing a narrative
literally
that's exactly what she's not because
she's still using her name exactly and
she knows that people are still going to
look for her under her name for that
reason because it makes our money it's a
continuation of what that gave her the
popularity and she's now using it to to
get the income that she now feels that
she deserves basically I think she is
totally entitled to that she's her own
personality now and her whole thing is
speaking out against the corn industry
but the reason why she's using that name
is because it's like
it's funny when your parents talk to you
and things come back to you it's like
you know that's what I say sometimes do
the best things that you want to be and
be who you want to be while you're young
because ultimately the reason why
they're still using these corn star
names is because they're on borrowed
time now they wasted all this time if
you know if you notice the bottom line
in all these situations people are angry
because this is time time is the
currency you can never get back I mean I
think it's just back to accountability
like women don't want to take
accountability for anything yeah like
she I mean I would respect it more
sorry I would respect it more if she
doesn't use words like I was coerced
like and she just owned it like I did it
it was stupid I'm moving on yeah and
changed her name I just can't how much
can you regret it if you have the same
name like if if that was me and I was so
ashamed I wouldn't want him anything to
do with it I wouldn't want anyone to
associate that name with me yeah I think
he's Devil's Advocate again I just
believe that they're using these names
like he said they're not taking
accountability one but two because they
feel like they're on borrowed time so
they're trying to find this minimal
thing to help them
still reap the benefit of that time that
they wasted do you see what I mean yeah
I disagree
I feel like it's almost like another
bailout for women's bad decisions so you
can go on like a hoe apology tour it's
like you can do that and then go back
and make more money apologizing for it
it's like it's like a system yeah that
needs to be broken to be honest do you
think that birth control weight makes
women more [__]
[Laughter]
birth control was banned would you be
more would you be less promiscuous like
would you sleep around less would you be
more careful with who you slept with I
mean I still don't look around I'm not
saying you do I'm just like would you be
more careful birth control okay outside
of the Doms it doesn't
it's not like you're blocking yourself
from SD you know like so whether you're
on birth control or not you're still at
risk of those things so I don't think it
makes a difference if you're in birth
control or not in terms of how
promiscuous you are because it's not
protecting you against diseases and so
you're just basically it's just
protecting you from pregnancy that's the
only thing so you're still at high risk
for all the things that are out there so
to use birth control as an excuse to be
promiscuous that says excuse so I'm just
wondering if you think you so you think
a girl that's promiscuous is going to be
equally as promiscuous with or without
birth control absolutely yeah but I
think being promiscuous with the partner
I think that would change for me like
I'd be a lot more careful with my
boyfriend to say then if birth control
was not permitted in the UK I think I'd
have to be more careful with my
boyfriend but it wouldn't make me not
sleep her right that's that's just not
my type of drip would you get married
like quicker if birth control was banned
I think I think yeah I think I think I'd
probably I feel like you'd I feel like
taking away birth control would allow
people to settle quicker and settle for
less quicker if that makes sense so I
feel like it would take away that option
of being able to make more of a choice
because I think
yeah you just you yeah it just changes
everything I think not being because I
think back in the day when people you
did used to fall pregnant at 16 and
stuff when I speak to my parents and
people that are around their age group
literally everyone would know if you
went to the clinic to get something like
it's not like now where you can go there
it's confidential and they would make it
work they'd have shotgun weddings the
dad would get yeah you're marrying my
daughter like my mom would say she could
never go down to the local Clinic
without her mom my mom said there was
two girls in her high school class that
got pregnant they're both still married
to the guy okay they just they just made
it worse
um condoms when you say birth control do
you mean everything or do you mean just
like I got pills I meant pills because I
mean from my personal experience when I
between the ages of 21 and now 25 I
didn't take birth control and I was
still like having sex sometimes the guys
that I dated I start I went back on
birth control when I went into a
long-term relationship where I felt like
um I know this person doesn't have
anything I know that like I'm not taking
any risks I still had sex before I still
you would just use condoms before I just
use condoms yeah because I don't want
any diseases is it because it was less
frequent because you weren't dating
someone is that why you chose to go on
birth control it was I think there's a
period of time if I was dating for
someone for like three or more months at
that point I'd be like oh maybe we
should think about this now
um as a more like viable option for us
um but I had sex I had one night stands
I still slept with people you know and
you take a risk when you do that but
[Laughter]
anyone here think birth control makes
you [__] anyone Noah I do I do yeah
do you take it no I don't take it I've
ever taken it
um not really no oh that's a yes that's
not really very very short like six
months why did you stomp
um I stopped because I just
wash your contraception by the way but
you took for six months uh it was an IUD
oh okay yeah but I don't know I started
like dating a guy and then it was just
like how do I put it I just felt like I
felt like turning off your uh like your
I just felt like it was going to be bad
in the long term you know what I mean
like I just felt like it like at some
point it would make me like something
would happen like I felt like there
would be side effects I didn't feel any
side but you didn't in the six months
that you took it you didn't feel any
what what side effects were you worried
about sorry I'm like interviewing you
know
um I just I was just nervous I wanted a
lot of care I want a lot of kids so I
was just nervous I couldn't have a lot
of kids it doesn't affect your fertility
though that's not what I like I don't
know about an IUD I don't know much
about I have to be honest I don't know
much about iuds themselves I know
they're very painful to put in I I just
felt like you just never know with that
type of stuff
so I I just I just felt like doctors
that are selling the stuff have an
incentive to lie to you yeah and I just
I I didn't I'm not a science person I'm
not going to pretend like I understood
it I just was like um I don't know but I
still stand on I do think birth control
makes you [__] overall yeah did you
feel [__] when you were on it then
no actually no but I think by and large
I think by and large it does I think
you're more likely to make crazy
decisions when you're on birth control
did you make any crazy decisions on
birth control no then what do you think
though
because I'm on it for a long period of
time so I think six months is a long
time it's long enough to see if you're
on a side effects yeah but I was with
the same guy so it was like yeah but
like what about it makes you think that
it it makes women [__] like I just
think when you have a bailout of a bad
decision you're more likely to make it
sure so I think if you if you have a
Fail-Safe for making a bad decision
you're more likely to make it and I
think I avoided a lot of like bad
decisions because I wasn't on birth
control most of my life
so you felt like making slushy decisions
but haven't because you're like I'm not
on birth control ever yeah sure
interesting like what like being at a
party and you're like oh I can see this
guy oh I'm not in birth control so I
won't like that kind of thing
um
I mean I don't really want to get like
it wasn't like it wasn't like a party or
anything it was just like I don't know
maybe someone I was dating like I'd just
have to like think about more what the
consequence would be you think you might
do it sooner yeah yeah okay yeah so but
if there's like a small window for you
to get pregnant
then effectively birth control doesn't
really have much say in terms of you
sleeping around really and truly because
if you can like you know there's all
these apps that you can have a look at
and I was just always nervous like I
just always like never wanted to be
pregnant like outside of marriage so I
was just always scared to be honest
because I mean women go on birth control
for different reasons of course we have
like for acne but in terms of some
people go on it because they don't want
to be pregnant or have that kind of
unexpected pregnancy but there's like
other reasons why they decide to go on
birth control whether it's I don't think
it's because they want to sleep around
well I mean I mean just like what else
is it for you mentioned earlier acne and
things like that yeah but I'm asking
around the room no one's on it for acne
some people I take it I know people that
take it to regulate them you're talking
about exceptions and not the rule so I'm
talking about the I think most girls
take birth control to not get pregnant
yeah that's what's for yeah yeah and so
I'm talking about the rule I mean if we
can if we have every conversation we
have to bring up the exception like
we're gonna be talking all day I'm
talking about the rule
um I think I don't know I feel like
passing for me after hours on
contraception because that with my
boyfriend I don't want to feel like I've
got to be precautious in terms of having
a baby because like you said Pearl I I
don't want to have a child with someone
that I'm not going to spend the rest of
my life with so I was always paranoid
about having a baby by accident and
obviously I'm still very young so I'm
ovulating I'm it it's less likely for me
to not be pregnant I mean it's less
likely for me to
yeah not be pregnant and pregnant so for
me it's a situation where that's why I
was on contraception because I didn't
want any form of like oopsies no no I
didn't want that but I also feel like I
think
Caribbean right right and I feel like
here there's this sort of thing where
the doctors are quick to recommend birth
control whereas I asked for it but like
here like I've got friends who were on
it from like 16 and I'm like that's a
crazy age because I think it was to kind
of
um help them with cramps but I'm like
cramps is like something you have like
probably five days out of the month so
why is it so much of a thing of an
agenda where the doctors are quick to
recommend it rather than it be your
choice when you feel like okay this is
you know I'm getting into adulthood this
is my decision rather than it being
recommended so that's why I think a lot
more people are on it because from a
young age it's just like it's the agenda
of the doctor to be like hey go on this
like my mom would have never dreamed of
like telling me at a young age to like
go on birth control it's just I always
told me not to yeah I just I just felt
like long-term like there would be some
side effect from basically tricking your
body into thinking you're pregnant every
month for years I don't know what it is
I'm not a science person I don't know
yeah that was
did you know that if you look at the
divorce rate and the rate of women on
birth control they're like the same
what do you mean
let me let me find it I'm gonna send it
to King
horse rate
what is the lack of correlation or it
just happens to be the same as if like
married women are often on birth control
no default is it difficult I mean yeah
so I'm gonna send this to King
um
do you mean like women on birth control
are getting more divorces
because if you look at it from a history
perspective the divorce Reform Act came
in 1969 which is when you could
basically get a divorce for no reason
and birth control became freely
available in 1974. oh you hold on so
those two things would obviously
correlate but that doesn't mean that
there's a correlation it just means that
those things happen at the same time you
could argue that
I think that you know I asked my grandma
my grandma is um very sick she like so
I've been asking her like life questions
lately
and I asked her because she was you know
around in the 70s when you know people
started getting divorced a lot like
you're right no fault divorce was
implemented and I asked her like why she
thought that
women like why why the like what changed
in relationships
my grandma said birth control
now again it might it might not be
related but look at this chart it's
actually kind of crazy
sorry to say that by the way yeah same
thread oh [__] yeah I know it's okay
she's she's like um like yeah she's
she's
um
she's been sick for a while so it's kind
of like
um
is that age on the left
um no
King did you get it I sent it to you on
Insta
I think the correlation between that
could be back to when they say that when
a woman sleeps with more than five
people those divorce rate tends to cheat
because she's she's in a habit of just
moving on when it gets tough or moving
on at that point so the correlation
would be that she's making more choices
to sleep with men because she doesn't
have to make she's got that bailout that
you're saying her body count then goes
up which means she's less likely to
stick around in a situation that she's
not used to dealing with the point I was
making though is that like divorce
divorce rules divorce rates and birth
control would obviously go up at the
same time because birth control was made
freely available on the NHS in the 70s
and divorce without any reason was
basically introduced in the late 60s it
would happen at the same time is it just
the same numbers or is it I'm going to
show you the chart it's the
um
it should be that like the first one on
the left that's on the screen do you see
it
on the left yeah on the left top corner
is
is that to match your point of women
being more approach to us that's a good
thing that's what I mean okay but I can
understand in that point okay you're
you've recently divorced and like if you
wanted you got seatbelts on you're
probably driving more you know what I
mean but with these women on the birth
control before they got divorced or
after they got divorced I think probably
also I like going on birth control
because they've had their kids and now
they can't deal with a husband because
they've had his kids I don't know that
is that is common women do divorce men
um I've interviewed I've interviewed a
divorce attorney and that's what they
say they said they'll get the two kids
and then stop sleeping with the husband
and then divorce him yeah because if
he's not pulling his weight and they're
doing all the work with the kids they
wouldn't be attracted I sense like a
little bit of an anger towards man from
you
and it doesn't sound like it based on
how you're talking no I think because
you're like he's not pulling his weight
why doesn't he just fight for his kids
like you always kind of automatically
take the woman's side I think that you
can take down that chart they see it I
would argue that right now that that's
just the room I'm in that I feel the
need to to pull that but in general like
no I love men and like the men I know
and the circles I'm in are what is What
is marriage to you
um well when I get married that would be
like I want to get married and then I
want to have my babies and you know
that's what's that like what's the point
of marriage
uh for me it would just be making us one
unit and that to me is like my forever
and we are now financially connected
with everything connected we're gonna
have each other's children and we're
gonna spend our lives together okay so
you do believe like when you get married
it's forever
yeah okay in an Ideal World okay and so
do you believe that it's in in sickness
and in health for richer for poorer for
better for worse yes okay so then not
when the man isn't pulling his weight
now
what I was saying though is that like
she might not want to sleep with him
that doesn't mean she doesn't love him
and she wouldn't stay with him but she
may stop having sex with him if he's not
if so she uses sex as a way to control
him if he's not doing well she might not
be attracted to him why why is she not
attracted to him big
he's attracted to somebody who doesn't
like help them and like do you believe
in Duty what do you mean by that like do
you believe you have duties in a
marriage or do you believe you should
just do what you want what makes you
happy but are you implying that sex is a
duty I am do you do you believe that sex
is a duty sex is a really complicated
thing I'm a person with a really high
sex drive I can't imagine like not
having sex with my boyfriend every day
what would you do if your boyfriend
stopped having sex with you I would find
it really difficult which is why I
understand that there's so much nuances
topic so I feel like I do have like and
also women don't take rejection as well
as men do often in the bedroom
um but like I also understand that there
are situations in a marriage where you
may go through a dry spell because
you're busy because you're stressed
because you haven't had two children and
it's like physically impossible
I understand like if you have medical
issues but outside of medical issues
we're just talking normal why would you
not want to sleep with your husband
I think that attraction can ebb and flow
especially when you're very stressed
it's hard enough yeah it's hard for me
to speak on because I've not been in
that situation myself so I can only
speak on like based on my friends
experience and what they've told me of
like I don't want to sit with my husband
because I don't see him anymore and like
he's working all the time and you know
what I mean it's hard to for me to speak
from myself because I've never been that
scenario do you think that men get
married thinking their wives will stop
sleeping with them no nobody gets
married because they're not going to
sleep with each other okay so don't you
think that's a bit unfair to men to like
they're already risking so much going
into marriage they're risking you
falsely accusing them of abuse they're
risking all their assets and now they
can't even get sex out of it I think
women get married wanting to have sex I
don't think anyone wants to not have sex
but whose choice is it typically to not
have sex the men or the women the woman
okay so it's the women not sleeping with
the man often I would say yeah that's
okay and you'd agree so would you agree
that that's unfair to men
no I don't think you're entitled to
somebody's body
but so you don't think sex is a duty
from wives to husbands not a duty no I
think I think it's a lovely thing that
you can share in I think intimacy is
very important in a relationship and I
think if sex stopped forever you might
get divorced over it I think intimacy is
incredibly important but do I think that
it's ever owed and do I think the
expectation of owing would make anyone
want it more no but not oh but like
shouldn't you want to do that yeah I do
want to like with my boyfriend but it's
hard to right but I'm saying like like
it's just like the way you're you're
speaking it's kind of like do whatever
you want in marriage like do what makes
you happy do do what you feel is right
but it's like if you want a long and
happy marriage how are you going to do
that if you're not sleeping with your
husband but if you're having sex when
you don't want to with your husband I
can't imagine that but it must be a
terrible feeling do you do you think
that sometimes in marriage you're gonna
have to do things you don't want to do
for the family sex is a very unpleasant
thing to do if you don't want to do you
can just play there what are you really
doing why would you get married though
if that's if that's an option
for you with that person I think it goes
back to when you asked why do you want
to get married I think I don't want to
get married to feel like a unit to want
to have kids with someone to want to
love someone I'm getting married because
I can't wait to enjoy that day with that
person just for us to enjoy it's like a
declaration of me showing you again why
I love you it just comes with a lot more
responsibility in terms of like you said
we come together as a unit financially
on paper but it shouldn't change the
status of your your love your
relationship you know I think when you
get with someone and you say to yourself
this is the guy that I want to marry you
have a duty to never stop trying if
you're at a point in a relationship
where you feel like you don't know if
you want to try with this person anymore
the option of getting married should
never be an option because you when you
get into a relationship that's why
relationships fail because people don't
understand that when love is true love
it becomes a thing of you're not selfish
and you you vow to without that marriage
you vow to always try when it's hard
when I'm in a mood when I'm on my period
when everything's heightened I still try
for that person and a marriage doesn't
Define that and I really hope you get
that but there is a million different
factors that recent relationships break
up and yeah as much as you try and also
I don't think in marriages
I think there's a million stupid factors
that marriages break up yeah yeah I
think yeah I really do I think that
women get divorced for a lot of stupid
reasons like what
um Financial I think is pretty dumb
um not being happy anymore I think
that's pretty dumb
um I think really anything outside of um
I'll give you infidelity like if he gets
another girl pregnant
I'm gonna give you that one you're so
generous yeah thank you I am so good
thank you
um I'm gonna say abuse there's one
um and honestly I don't even really
believe in divorce I believe in
separation you know and then you try to
work it out but I'll give you abuse I'll
give you abuse I'll give you that
um
trying to think that's really it abuse
nowadays someone came on my pod and said
you should get divorced for not doing
the dishes so you know
marriage has changed I guess
um
that's all I can think of those two
that's what I got can I ask a question
because she's about sex and Duty within
a marriage so do you think the piece of
paper that says I do the marriage
certificate gives is then lifelong
consent to have sex with me no matter
the situation I wanna I wanna I wanna do
one caveat it is not okay for him to
forcefully have sex with you ever okay
but I think I think one I don't see the
point of getting married if you believe
divorce is on the table for damn near
anything what's the point be in a
relationship don't get married like I I
just genuinely don't see the point I
don't think there's many people that get
into a marriage and stand there on that
day thinking oh I've got a way out and I
have many years you know but there's I
think your actions speak louder than
words so if you do it then you think it
you thought it at least once yeah
um so I'd like that caveat that's that's
not okay no no grape none of that none
of that but I think as a wife you should
have sex with your husband whenever he
wants pretty much no matter what his
behavior is or I don't think you should
use sex to control your husband I think
that's wrong so I think it's actually
trust you sex to control you
um why do two wrongs make a right are we
on the playground no yeah so so I think
a lot of women use sex to try to control
their husbands wrong wrong I think
that's mean men need sex because then I
don't if you do that I don't feel bad if
you get cheated on I don't feel bad not
even a little bit
and I feel like they do that sometimes
because they're actually not strong
enough to actually stand up in a
situation when they should so they use
other anomalies to get out what has been
swept under the mat rather than facing
that argument or facing what he'd done
that was wrong
at that moment at that time so if that's
like cooking things like that like
you'll stop doing and things rather than
being direct and not being naive and
then like exert that in a whole like you
said the wrong way instead of the right
way and communicating I think that if
you want to get divorced for damn near
anything just don't give me like what's
the point of getting married like what's
then just just be in a relationship I
had someone I'm not gonna name names
Destiny say that say that you should get
divorced over chores oh go get that's
fine it's ridiculous that's fine if you
want to do that but what's then don't
get married marriage is supposed to be
for sick or for poorer for better for
worse he did make it quite a good point
but you're right it is a stupid reason
but he did make it sound quite it is
so good can I also point out though that
Destiny is actually the only one married
here though
I'm not married yeah but like am I gonna
draw experience space you know I had a
video coming out about this but I have
an aunt you know and she expressed that
like her concern was she couldn't stay
um like she was so frustrated with her
husband right and she she was like he's
so messy I just couldn't deal with it
and she's been married like 20 years and
honestly she's one of the most feminine
women that I know like that like she's
just one of those ants that comes in you
know and you just feel like at home you
know you know the aunt right she's like
the sweetest lady and she was like yeah
I was so mad but then I thought every
time I picked up my sock I would just
say I love you Jason I love you romance
I was her husband and her son and she
said I had to change my thinking and
stop complaining and just do it and
think of it as doing something that I
love for them so like what's a better
mindset get divorced over chores or
learn how to learn how to love the
person because you're not perfect either
and that's the thing I was just lost the
word I now remember it that that love
she that moment she made a decision of
it not being egotistic love and actually
being true love because she's now not
trying to change a person or continue to
be frustrated she's accepting that
person for who they are and making that
work for her so if she has to tell
herself that every single time that
works for her some people might just
throw it and be like he could pick up
when he comes in that might work for
them but that's when love is not
egotistic and it's true
[Music]
um
I think there's any other topic I wanted
to cover I think that's pretty much it
you have any questions guys any anything
you want to talk about
can I ask you another birth control
question
if it's not too nosy always I might be a
little bit nosy but you don't have to
answer there's no pressure If you got
into a new long-term relationship now
would you go on birth control would you
consider it or would it just be
completely out of them no no I don't I
just I just want a lot of kids and I
just I don't want to do anything that
would like jeopardize that so and I it
may not but I just don't I don't even
want to take that risk personally
um
I think back to switching topics the
marriage topic I feel like
also I feel like there's a lot of kids
having kids these days and that leads to
kind of unprofound like child neglect
and I think households because sometimes
it's not planned or people quite young
they when you're in a relationship
people don't understand you have to have
the patience to adopt that person as now
being a parent so as much as you was in
love with them as just you and them you
have to give room for that person to
change and accept them changes and
sometimes when you fight the changes
that frustration kicks in which then
breaks up a home and I feel like divorce
is a lot more just like I'm gonna go out
with you or marriage is like I'm gonna
go out with you and break up with you as
divorce now because I feel like society
and the way things have changed from
tradition has kind of changed the
morality around marriage and I think the
actual reasoning behind marriage has now
been shifted and it's now you take it as
you want it and there's certain things
in life that I feel like cannot be
changed it's meant to be the way it's
meant to be and if you can't adopt that
nature then leave it alone
I agree with you I I think that a lot of
times
people look at marriage as like a
long-term relationship it's I don't
actually I think divorce should be
illegal
illegal yeah except for I'll give you
I'll give you those two and if I think
of one or two more I'll add them but I
would make it a legal band band but why
because I just don't see the point like
what is the point of marriage like
marriage is supposed to be for for
better for worse in sickness and in
health for richer or for poorer like
that that's what marriage is supposed to
be so if you can get out then it's not
marriage that's my opinion on it um now
I don't want women getting abused long
term that's that's I'm not for that so
I'll let those women I'll let them out
but even just when you see like I've
known children who like obviously like
growing up with my friends I've had
friends of mine they've been like God I
wish my parents had got divorced growing
up because all they ever did was argue
it's not abusive they just don't get on
they just don't love each other they
just shouldn't have stayed together and
I and I hear that from kids but
oftentimes those kids turned out pretty
well yeah and so now like would they
really feel that way if they only saw
their father six days a month is that a
better outcome
it's hard to argue but because I wasn't
in that situation but I think for a lot
of people like I've heard people say a
lot like I wish my parents were divorce
because they would have been happier it
would have been less traumatic to not
try and play the Wii and hear people
scream each other it's a bit spoiled I
don't know in some situations because I
feel like don't get me wrong like
I feel like it's a bit spoiled because
you know nothing's perfect there's not a
perfect home there's not a perfect
family there's not a perfect person it's
not a perfect relationship it's about
never stopping trying so then parents
I'm grateful to my parents for never
stopping trying because I understand
what a man's duty is because my dad is
around my dad is an active role in my
life if my mum pulled a plug or my dad
pulled the plug would I be as confident
would I know my duty is also as a woman
because I can see my mom and the way she
is with my father and I think that's why
it's important back to when you said
like you're so paranoid about when you
have children because I want my children
to have that and not because I just want
that for myself with my partner is
because I think it's a it's part of that
Foundation of them being the best people
that they can be be and that's why there
is men and women because we have roles
to play in our children's lives and I
think people that come from I'd say
broken homes they would agree that
sometimes they go through more traumatic
things you know they go through a lot
more challenges mentally sometimes even
physically in life than people that have
come from a whole household if that
makes sense and what's the better
solution get divorced or work it out
figure out how to get along like like in
those games the most qualified person to
answer this is just a divorced woman
yeah but every uh relationship has its
own unique set of circumstances and I
um level everything you guys are saying
about like how you think these things
are going to go and stuff like that and
that's and that's great but life doesn't
always work out like that
I agree but um I also do agree with you
I do think a lot of people do rush into
marriage
um because obviously you see the amount
of people that you know that get
divorced like the percentage rate is so
high and a lot of the time I I don't
even have the conversation
you know I'm actually not that ass about
you know getting married I feel like a
lot of men are starting to come around
to that yeah and it gets shut down
straight away and I know you can say you
know you want your children to have the
same last name but then after that you
know
even on a financial one if you are the
person that makes the majority of money
in the relationship I'm saying that's my
situation but
um yeah you are it's gonna be a struggle
and a lot of men just aren't as fuss
about it because they do take a lot more
risks if they are the person that's
earning more money like my mum and Dad's
been together
I can't marry no what they've been
trying I think lockdown happened they
was meant to get married and then
lockdown happened and since then we're
just trying to work through things but I
think you know again I'm happy my mum
and dad didn't get married because that
is a memory I'd always have with God
willing I'd always have with them and
have of them you know but it showed me
that like you said like you going
through them things in a marriage is not
going to stop you like some again it's
wants and needs this like separating the
two you don't need to have your child
your child having the same last name as
you is not going to keep the family
together bro like that doesn't keep you
together that's that's a one it's not it
I wish there was a second marriage for
the girls like me that don't believe in
divorce because it's like as a guy why
would you get married like I can't think
of one good reason why would you do it
but but then that's that's why there's
prenups so if you're a strong believer
in not getting divorced then you have
those you can you can put those things
in place to you know if you were to
divorce between a certain amount of
years like you can like you can format
it to be something that would actually
almost like kind of in a way threatened
for him not to divorce you
um so there's these Provisions but I I
grew up in a household where my parents
got divorced
um and I can remember I was like in high
school I think I was like one year
before the last year and I found out
from my mom seeing a friend and she was
like oh how's your husband she's like oh
we're divorced and it happened when I
went a summer away and I remember I was
like absolutely devastated but looking
at it now like it didn't affect me like
my dad is still in the picture
um and I think fantastic that my mom
kind of set that example because my dad
was cheating and it was it was so
consistent that I at one point was like
he used to pick me up from school and my
mom used to travel because of work and
he picked me up and this lady was in the
front seat and I'm a daddy's girl so I
used to be in the front seat of that he
did not and she was in the front seat of
the car and I had to go in the back so
that happened like 2 days in a row and
then my mom came back from traveling and
I was like Mom who's this woman that
keeps on having me sit in the back seat
and the look that she gave me I was like
oh oh I was young I was probably like
seven and I understood but then after
that my dad used to do stuff because my
mom asked for a divorce like it was he
he signed the papers and she wasn't
nasty about it but my mom is a smart
woman in that like our home is under my
sister and my my name so it has nothing
to do with like him trying to take the
house and stuff like that but I'm very
grateful that my mom made that decision
because it's kind of showed me how a man
should treat me like did you did she get
remarried no no do you think the outcome
is better for her being alone
um absolutely because you know what like
she she's still open to how old is she
oh she won't she would dare won't let me
tell you her age but 60s early early
okay okay
um so you think life at like 75 is gonna
be happier for her but with by herself
instead of with a husband my mom is so
happy at this age it's my dad who you
can't tell him and this is like early
this is probably
2000 and I think nine they got divorced
you can't tell him today that's not his
wife he will call and he'll be like
where's my wife and she'll be like we've
been divorced for years but for him
he's at that point that was his wife who
else who else what other what other man
has had more of an impact on her or will
well
but it really and really like well it
really is his wife I mean yeah she's got
he you know he's got two beautiful kids
and for her it's like well
she always said you will there will come
a day while you'll be on this side and
I'll be on this side with the girls and
you will
want to appreciate what you had and for
him he's well my dad's like what 67 he's
a couple of years older no he's turning
70 in December and my dad I can see that
he is very aware like his friends were
cheetahs as well they've passed on and
so now their wives are widows but he
understands how much at that age you
need a woman in your life because he's
getting that although he has girlfriends
that that's nothing to him he wants that
woman where he can grow old with and
he's lost that opportunity so I can
really see it affecting my dad that up
to this day he has heartache because you
know of the choices that he made but
he's still never stopped so yes when did
when did he start no that's that's
another thing when did he start
um because they got married before me
um
you know when did he start and when did
he get caught is probably two different
things but to have the audacity I'm
talking about like this woman attacked
my mom and my sister and he he was he
continued to be with her and you know
sometimes in the Caribbean we're like
okay she put a spell on him and stuff
like that but
we couldn't understand why he would
choose this woman that he just met over
his family you know and it happens but I
couldn't see that he is really really
facing yeah big time and I think I mean
that are doing corn it's the same thing
when you do certain things and make
certain decisions you do see that not to
say karma but because once it's a
mistake the second time's always a
choice because it's now conscious you
can't make a mistake twice so he's seen
the unfortunate consequences of that and
it goes back to again with women doing
corn it's just your kids will then the
consequence that comes with that as
children you're still affected and you
know what I will say as well with what
your story was men always realize
everything too late they always realize
because even my parents like my parents
they're not together anymore they're
divorced but the way my dad used to
treat my mom compared to how he treats
her now that he can't have access to her
the way he did before is so different
like I personally think that if you
treat her like how he does now like the
respect that he does have for her now
and the way he speaks about her like if
he treated her like that when they were
married and when we were all living in
the same house like everything would
have been so different and I asked him
today like like his opinion on their
marriage he says like if he knew
everything that he knows now like he
thinks that things would have gone so
different but obviously my mom is so out
of that space is she remarried no so why
doesn't she just work it out if he's
treating her right he's he's remarried
but he's still but I'm not gonna lie
like he's still like you know what I
mean but you see the outcome seem worse
for both of your moms to be honest I
mean it depends how you look at it I
think that being alone at an old age is
worth is is worse but my mom is so much
more happier now that she's free from
him like she feels like she has her own
say in her life she can work for herself
and she has her children like she's so
much happier when she feels like she
doesn't have the burden of someone else
she's about to turn 50 next year but
right now like she's the happiest I've
seen her I just wonder if that'll be the
same like I we're supposed to live to be
90. so you know 70 to 90 I think it's
pretty lonely when you're by yourself
but can I you know like for example well
kind of because
um my grandparents died a year within
each other so my grandfather passed away
and my grandmother passed away a year
literally a year after because of um
heartbreak you know but like my mom she
does not look her age compared okay yes
my dad's a bit older and he doesn't look
old as well but you won't take my mom
for a 60 year old like you put her early
50s and she's just so much happier like
she she's an independent woman anyway so
it's not like the divorce affected her
like lost assets and stuff like that no
but in terms of Happiness absolutely
she's like she she can live past 90 in
my opinion healthy well and I hope I
hope they genuinely are like I'm I'm
just on the outside looking in and it
just seems like a lot of times women
leave their husbands and think the grass
is greener on the other side and they
end up by themselves and if that's a
happy outcome for them you know so be it
it just on the outside looking and
doesn't seem like that I was gonna say
as well because I I know women that have
stuck through things
for their reasons whether it be their
kids keeping their family homes together
and like he said men kind of do see
things later on and you know that when
you said in a relationship with money a
guy wants someone that will be there for
him though that's I'm saying that's
wrong of course he's wrong I'm not I'm
not like permitting adultery but I'm
saying it's one of them ones where
through that time where he was making
bad decisions you stuck through that
with him and you would then reap that
benefit then benefits I know I know a
couple like that where the it was really
similar like the dad was messing around
like crazy yeah and um they worked it
out and like they were happier than ever
later literally and it's like now like
I'm not saying you know your parents are
great and that's great but I'd say women
that I have seen not not stick that at
all kind of just made not that they were
cheated on but just split with men had
babies and not with them guys and
whatever now the women that did stick
that through seem a lot happier and a
lot more what I mean is a lot of stress
less stress-free like they're just like
for example they don't have mortgages to
worry about their kids are doing their
own things they're confident don't worry
about them so much and then the kids end
up having to take care of the mom when
she's by herself instead of the husband
yeah
um I was gonna show you guys this chart
have you guys ever seen the sexual
market value chart can you zoom in on
that just slightly
slightly
so this is I zoom in more okay more can
you go more
oh we can't go anymore
um okay you guys
um is there any way could you click the
other one on the right that'll be bigger
could you click the site maybe and see
if that helps
can you zoom in on that
okay and clicked click that I agree
there you go
okay so this is the chart of basically
dating options based on age so you can't
see it because it's it's basically 23 is
a woman's Peak we're about 38 is a man's
Peak
and that's basically your value in the
marketplace based on how many options
you have to the opposite sex so you'll
see around
um can you put your mouse over where 35
is
okay
yeah so that's the compared demand where
theirs goes up and so this is just
something that I see with older couples
when they do get divorced the men end up
getting remarried because they have more
of a leverage in the marketplace where
the women don't
yeah that explains why there's a lot
more yeah older guys dating like I've
got a lot of friends that are dating
that around my age 23 24 dating guys
that are like in their 30s and it's
working yeah
I prefer dating guys in their 30s
um and the because when women are over
the age of like I think it's 50 they
have a 25 like
I think there's I'm gonna butcher this
but it's basically like men under the
age of like 30 have a 25 chance of being
in a relationship and it flips after
like age 55 or 50. right
um see like from my mom she has the
options have happened someone in her
life but she just chooses not to because
I think she I think what she went
through with my dad was more than enough
like to start over and have those kind
of concerns okay would he be cheating I
think she's just like actually I Can Do
Bad All By Myself like you don't think
she'd prefer to be with a man she loves
and respects over being by herself like
if she could pick one of the two
but then it also goes back to like
and you know when we date we all always
have these kind of things okay is he
going to be faithful what's his history
for her to stop that all over again for
her it's like nah because there is a 90
chance that he's lying or he's there's a
90 chance yes that he's a liar and he's
a cheater absolutely so 90 of men you
think are liars and cheaters to stop
back at that age and I'm saying that
because I know of people in her in her
age group that are not that they were
divorced but they're dating again and
it's just kind of like you know they're
with people who don't add value to their
life like no they don't appreciate them
in confidence and stuff like that and
they're just settled but they're unhappy
but that's the point of the graph is
that like they can't get the best people
anymore because they're older um no like
I know someone who's been with someone
for unlike early 50s who's been with
someone for more than 10 years and
they're not happy but they're afraid of
letting go of that because they have to
start all over again but they're not
happy but I think we have a tendency
sorry saying that 90 that you said not
we can't that and I get the situation
and I get sometimes it can be that
trauma stays there but you can't then
base every man off of people that you
know and I think we have a tendency of
doing that in terms of that percentage I
don't think is right because there are
men out there that are willing to start
again there are men out there that have
been cheated on for 10 years by their
their wife if there are men out there
that have had to go through trauma with
children to say you know there are men
out there that share the same types of
stories that us women do the the
difference is we're a lot more vocal
about it because we don't have to take
accountability in a sense the way
Society is made you know things to be
where men it's like okay but if she did
cheat on you it's like but what did you
do was you there for her did you do this
for her it's like we're making excuses
why she was cheating on him but if we
say oh a man was cheating on us it's
like oh he had that right yeah I mean
and the other thing is we don't talk
about women's part to playing cheating
I'm not I don't know your story
personally but one out of four marriages
is sexless one out of four so if you're
not sleeping with your husband you're
surprised someone else is yeah exactly
it's not even some men just love
cheating like no some you're right just
some do but it's a small percentage of
men that can cheat most most men one out
of three men under 30 are either sexless
or virgins in today's society three one
and three it seems like a lot it is
we're all going for a small percentage
of men look it do you guys do you guys
think this room are we top ten percent
of women
in the world out of every 10 women top
10 as a group instead of finances no
looks I'll put myself there don't mind
me today hello yeah I'm getting here in
the top she could look like a movie star
in a minute do you think you're you're
top ten percent I just said that yeah no
no you're not that's your opinion I mean
I'm not trying to be here
and Brianna came from the island next to
me okay murder without money come on
let's just not no money has a lot to eat
yeah look at Rihanna at eight come on
I'm not I'm not saying you're bad
looking but I'm not taking it as that
Rihanna you think you're at the same
level as Rihanna yeah call me delusional
like that website but I do
literally what what makes a woman what
what makes you value Rihanna
um in thin I mean I mean I wouldn't say
she's I wouldn't say she's a 10
um now because she's a bit older but I
would say when she was 22 I would put
her at a nine or ten um because she was
young
um she was thin she was tall she looked
like a model very symmetrical face yeah
I think it's wonderful that you feel
like that about yourself and I think
every woman should feel like that yeah
when we do look at objectively it's like
would it be all of us sat here or would
it be Margot Robbie and Rihanna and you
know what I mean I think that's the
points
parents have 10 outcomes so you either
have modeling contracts or nines nines
and tenses so we're going by size
basically because everything has to do
with size modeling contract size
who even like we're over complicating it
guys like just who get the most
attention by men if you're walking down
the street
and I mean like in terms of attention
like oh okay like I'd want to take her
home like she's wifey material not just
oh she's got a big fake butt yeah
that's what she's talking about but then
we talk about okay I get you but we talk
about size and then you're like size and
big butt you get it like we're just
talking about like attractive just yeah
just looks not personality you know what
else you could bring to the table Yeah
be in the table like actually just pure
looks like what made the final attract
top 10 percent so is that the only thing
that men look for on women it starts
with
just asking about look sir yeah yeah
look for this particular question no I
understand I just I assumed that the
point you're making was like the a lower
percentage of women are going for the
top 10 men and so do we think we're the
top 10 women but then that's obviously
basing it on the fact that men are only
looking at looks and not the other
things that men do look at other things
but it starts with looks you have to be
over a certain threshold for Matt yeah
see
we all come from different backgrounds
and cultures so where I come from I'm
valued highly as a woman as a black
woman it's only when we integrate
ourselves like for example I use my
example of coming to England where
there's a whole bunch of different
aspects on what men think is beautiful I
always remember when I went to a reggae
concert and
um there's this guy he balanced into me
a Rasta and he was like sorry empress
and it I was like oh shoot like I was
like why did that make me feel
like really respected and I was like
I've forgotten that that's what I grew
up with it's only when I come here that
it's you know there's a sort of
disrespect in how women are greeted in
the Caribbean you're greeted like
Empress Queen you know and it's not just
words they value you so when I come here
and I have to look at Beauty stands and
size and other than that there's no
brain it's a western half of these women
who are how long were you there till
till how old um high school so I was
there until 17 18. 18. so that's like
yeah so when I come over here and then
you have different cultures who tell you
what beauty standards are and like what
you should accept that's just hair and
let me tell you England has a lot of
influence you have Instagram I do okay
nines and tens get nines and tens
outcomes on Instagram they could be in
Eastern Europe or Russia but the the
rich man will find them what are they
showing though to get that attention I I
look at sometimes it's sexual you know
sometimes it's that but but beautiful
come on a girl that looks like Margot
Robbie I don't even know what that is if
she just showed um there's another one
Rihanna at 22. they would find her yeah
yeah they were in London absolutely but
look at the ages that we're comparing
their beauty and we're speaking about
them now we're saying Rihanna when she
was in her 20s but Rihanna's like but
this I think she's 36. yeah but yeah
that's where you're going to go go off
the graph yeah okay so I find it more
attractive she's a nine at 22. and I
don't know so she's like a six seven
seven it's because she's got a kid now
that she's devalued yeah they say that
you know yeah to Matt to men um a kid
subtracts two points so if you're an
eight and you have a kid each kid is two
points
but then also Society tells us that as
women because of like how men mature
that we need to go for older guys yeah
and so it's the sort of thing where
half half the people I know they'll want
a guy like 10 years is
they can start at 10 years older and so
it's just kind of like and it's not
maybe financially they're more stable
but in terms of how they get treated yes
probably a little bit better because
they've had that life where they've had
kids so there's no pressure for them to
have kids or there's more of a financial
stability they've probably own a house
by then you know but
there's different things you know but I
think it's about like the Western
Community though because I think what
you're going to look for I mean I'm
Jamaican like what you're going to look
for in the Caribbean is different to
what the stats would be like over here
you know we're part of like a Western
Community in terms of men are like I
don't think yeah I disagree with that I
think I think beauty is just crazy I
know what you mean like yes we do
slightly you know you do yeah there's a
slight difference but I think a very
good looking girl you know I'm saying
like men and women though I'm saying
like for example like what I'm saying is
we're not being in terms of what you're
saying in terms of beauty and stuff I'm
saying like I would disagree with you in
terms of we're not being realistic on
like you said what I'm what a man would
actually gravitate to if that's be or
highly gravitate to because like the 20
of men
I mean in that 20 I don't think much of
them are going to be tubby do you know
what I mean I think they're going to be
quite athletic or masculine in that way
do you know what I mean so I'm saying in
terms of being realistic I agree with
you in a sense where there there's a
certain type of woman that men would
gravitate to more right my only point
was that everyone here who had the
highest percentage 20 percent
like when we did the delusion calculator
what was it who had the highest
percentages and you picked what was it
20 yes 15. yeah I picked 15 and it came
up to 13.8 okay yeah 13 that so out of
us we're all we're all competing for up
to 13 percent of guys would you say that
you're in the top 10 women though
because what you've disc what you've
described in the podcast is like what
makes an attractive woman is like slim
you're slim you've got a symmetrical
face you have feminine features and
you've got long hair you wear dresses
like so what makes you not
that 10
um
I I think I'm cute but I don't I don't
think I'm the top 10 of facial symmetry
um I think I could probably lose a
little weight you know
um I think you could I've seen you'll
cook things you have lost weight you
look great thank you thank you thank you
I did see your Chef things on on Twitter
yeah no um I've lost a bit of weight but
no I mean I think it'd be quite
delusional to say I'm in the top temper
like if I'm looking at Margot Robbie and
Rihanna at 22 do I think that I compete
with them and we're going to be talking
to the same men no no I I and I don't
think that's a bad thing to say that
most people are average I don't think
there's anything wrong with just being
an average person but do you want the do
you want a mat as a six foot woman do
you want a man taller than you do you do
you I do ideally but um I don't mind if
they're a bit shorter that you settle
um I wouldn't I wouldn't say subtle um I
think that settling implies that like
you somehow don't deserve what you get I
think you always deserve what you get
like I think if you deserve if if you
qualify for the top 10 percent of men
you'll get them and if you haven't got
them you don't qualify I think you can
get info thank you I appreciate that a
lot of men don't even want a 10 anyway
we want like a nice seven or eight like
a really good looking girl but not super
arrogant the self-conceited in all the
things that tend to come with the most
attractive girl so there's no shame in
not being in the top ten percent or
being a ten like I don't understand why
it has to be like a little girl yeah
he's like no you're still a great person
you're still a good looking girl it's
fine you don't have to be a 10 you can
feel a ten but it doesn't mean like you
know I agree with you but it's I think
and I completely understand but it's
like who are you to tell someone they're
not attend like I'm not not not not
being disrespectful not in that but I'm
just in conversation like
it's all raised on what we were told is
a 10. especially in today's beauty
standards you know so we can't be picky
and choosy because people are who they
are in terms of tens five six I think we
have to live in reality though like I
think like a lot of times as women like
we just live in delusion and we're never
told the truth ever and I I think it's
it's quite delusional to to think that
I'm on the same level as Rihanna I I
think that's delusional well I'm told
the truth I've grown on that so yeah I'd
say I'm definitely told the truth like
if I'm like I'm a dancer if I do a dance
my dad's gonna tell me I need to go on
train I mean if I'm putting on a bit of
weight I'm just gonna tell me to go get
in that gym girl so I've always been
told the truth I think that's why I just
reality is reality you can't fight it in
it my mom tells me the truth all the
time like she but it's the way she does
it but she tells me the truth all the
time so
but we just have to this isn't another
topic but beauty standards like what who
we to say beauty is this you know like I
agree if you if you're with your woman
and you choose your woman right to you
she's a 10. so other people she's not
that's me you men just lie
do men lie yes women men like to get
books no but if you have your woman
would you I don't I I don't lie about
men do you lie so you don't like but
your man's not you no I don't lie
because I you know if if I was gonna go
out to a girl I find her attractive yeah
I mean yeah but a lot of men do lie and
try to say the sweetest thing when you
said Jamaican I thought bloody oh you're
gonna say Ireland boys Ireland boys are
the most promiscuous let's be honest
they're saying that Queen
they love a pillow talk you gotta look
at ladies
yeah they do I don't even think like I
feel like beauty standards there's just
hot and not hot that's my opinion I
don't think I think most men
will look at every every race and just
hot or not hot in general yeah
I've never worried about that then like
my
my partner is probably in the top
percentage of and that he earns well he
buys me nice bags he takes me nice
places he's six foot three
but obviously I didn't know what he
looked like before I met him but like
I've never struggled and like I'm
overweight like I'm not the best looking
woman in the world Margot Robbie could
absolutely take me in a beauty pageant
100 times good for you but like I've
never struggled with that I think a lot
there's so much more to it it's about
like your circles and who you're around
and but you're like what are you doing
you're not married no I don't want to be
right now but I'm saying the outcome is
marriage that most women are looking for
yeah so you you haven't really won until
you're married that's an interesting way
to look at relationships though I mean I
would just okay do you do you think that
marriage is above a relationship like
that's more committed but I do I don't
want that commitment right now okay and
that's fine no no problem
yeah I don't think it is though that's
but I you don't think you'd have an
easier time if you were thinner
I think that I've always done so I've
been thin and I've always done well I
did better in entertainment when I was
thinner 100 yeah because I was more
attractive and so I got more actually so
if they pulled the top 10 20 of men and
they took a picture of you heavier and
thinner which one would they pick
typically thinner but that doesn't mean
that it's held me back I'm not saying
you can't it can't happen but I think I
just haven't struggled is what I'm
trying to add well I mean you're a
pretty girl you know I mean yeah I mean
I'm not so I'm I'm not saying that you
can't have that outcome I just think if
we're going on a balance of
probabilities you have a modeling
contract right yeah so that means at
least facial you're above average yeah
well plus size model correct and so like
that worked out for you because you're a
pretty girl but most women are average
most people are not above average
yeah so of course you're going to
struggle less
you disagree with that no I no
moving on
um would you are you with an overweight
guy no no okay would you would you be
with one yeah before okay so you got no
problem
um okay I'm gonna close out the show
um
guys any final thoughts anything you
want to speak your piece on start here
and then go around no no thank you for
your time yeah thanks for coming go
ahead yeah thanks for your time but I'd
say beauty is in the eye of the beholder
so regardless of whether you're up there
you're not there whatever it is you know
you've always got your person and I
think what's meant for you will always
be for you and what's meant for you will
never pass you
yeah I agree I just want to say thanks
for having me I don't really have
anything else to say so
just want to say thank you um the only
thing for me not even on beauty is back
to The Narrative of men being vulnerable
because if we kind of stop our men from
being vulnerable then when we have sons
you know it's all mental health in men
is very high and so we need to observe
that and so how do we kind of help that
minimize from early days especially when
they're kids so that's it but lovely
show thank you very much uh thanks for
having me sorry for crying about your
personal life huh
um yeah follow me on Tick Tock it's
Peter blossom
thanks for having me Poe um fellas uh as
we've even touched on today you know a
lot of men do struggle to open up and
that's what I do coaching for I help men
open up and overcome their limitations
and become the best versions of
themselves so following me on Instagram
at step.up.coaching and also I've just
started a new challenge for people that
want to become more consistent in the
gym working on your mentality getting a
winning mindset
um so also checked out as well
okay guys I'm gonna Read Super chats
before we end the show
um Mr B93 we want cute fit um and mother
Vibes women Dave stop it I'm from
Jamaica you are no dance Queen you would
not get that attention if we were on the
road during Carnival a True Grit she's
being delusional uh Mr BT I don't rate
men but he definitely has a Chad look
true grant one Burger away from obesity
Mr b69 ratings starting with pearl six
five seven six four four a scout and
Bradley men don't care about ethnicity a
10 is a 10. how to get a 10
a 10 is a 10. how to how get to be a 10
in this order looks moral personality in
that order
um Oscar
uh Mr B3 men want quantity women want
quality that's life my 90 free-toe pie
um nothing sadder than seeing a lonely
old lady interracial relationships we
are headed to marriage equals a
five-year renewable contract
a scout and Bradley my parents fought a
lot when my dad died my mom cried for
about two months straight so what is
love of so what is love of you not
having your feelings Amelia
um colorful jacket lady is so triggered
Manny um don't make permanent permanent
decisions based on temporary feelings 93
toe pie we need to spend more time
research we spend more time researching
cars than our future spouses we spend
more time looking up cat videos than
um marriage facts 90 free-toe pie look
up FDA failures and you'll stay away
from birth control admin on Pearl since
corn is bad would you be embarrassed to
showing a picture of your feet and toes
and apologize about it after you got
married it's not being naked
um
how would you get um Justin Bieber on
the show 90 free top high I agree with
the Wendy's girls women are easy to
trick Manny F boiling water can make an
egg hard and a potato soft both in the
same environment don't let your
environment dictate your decisions or
desires literally incline look up the
state of two Ohio State football players
that accused of grape had consent on
video beforehand because the coaches
recommended it to them but still lost
their scholarships and three years to be
acquitted Xanax those
those who are forced have outs most
women in the west don't have similar
circumstances to park minimum wage jobs
exist a scout and Bradley everyone has a
choice the women who are dead broke
would never have thought about only fans
in their teens gals love but after their
after that gal's trade Isaac kids in
school today are being bullied with
their peers sharing naked pictures from
their mother's oafs it's not just your
kids that'll see that stuff hey you
Pearl make makes good points but y'all
let her off easy interracial
relationships during puberty ages 9 to
18 should be in the children's lives in
order to instill sexual discipline
respect sex and rules of dating a scout
and Bradley me on the grape thing the
flip side is when guys are graped but
they don't tell
um Assam G consensual non-consent is
what is called grape is a part of the
category consenting is not being able to
stop whatever actions are happening
Johnny f um maybe all relationships
should start online
um without putting a face to personality
twitch girls Falls for personality
traits rather than superficial traits um
Elise Alessandra
um
um Pia is looking so hot OMG LSPs I love
I make more money than all the men in
the chat
um okay well then why'd you send five
pounds
I'm just saying like I love you Alice
um admin if um if you ask most
prostitutes all of the men come to see
them to decompress and complain just as
much for sex Sergeant G I would want my
man to open up we can't use it against
them if they're only complaining and
being weak that's different Manny F men
don't want to open up because women will
use it against you in the end using
temporary feelings to justify permanent
decisions
um okay I think that's all of them okay
guys um thank you for watching a couple
announcements before we end the show um
the first is that we have two clips
channels subscribe to both just probably
clips and pearl daily
um four membership tiers the most
important one is the fourth one I can
give you tips on YouTube how to get a
million subscribers in a year and also
tips on how to recruit for a live show
IG just pearly things one um I almost
lost it so go follow in case they take
it again I'm also banned off at Tick
Tock right now I know I'm sad
um but I'm probably gonna I think wait I
have a new account it's just pearly
things so it's my original username
um I also guys sign up for our form that
should be in our Google form in the
description to have updates on our
future events like the